you're about to learn the python
programming language from scratch you'll
learn everything from setting up your
system to program with python to working
with apis bobby steerman from dig coding
teaches this course
hi everyone i'm bobby steven from
decoding and this is my python course
for beginners so if you're looking to
learn python or polish up on some skills
you've already got then you are in the
right place because in this course we'll
be covering topics such as setting up
our system to use python we'll be
looking at numbers strings data types
control flows classes and all the
fundamental things that sit in between
and before we close off the course we'll
then use those new found python skills
to write some python programs
but before we jump into it i'd just like
to say a big thank you to the guys free
cocam for publishing this course you
guys are fantastic you're doing an
outstanding job keep up the good work
and also keep that content coming that
is absolutely free so without further
ado let's jump straight into it
[Music]
so you can see here that i'm on python's
main website this is python.org
so this course has been designed around
their own documentation i've
extrapolated out the parts that i feel
are the fundamentals for you as a
beginner
but we will be becoming familiar with
their site because like i say i've
referenced the documentation quite a lot
so if you visit python.org hover over
downloads on the navbar you can see here
it's giving me the option to download
3.10.2 that's their latest and greatest
stable version of python as of the time
of recording this video so if i click
that that will download an installer
while it's downloading i will say that
as you become better at python and you
become a freelancer or a software
engineer then you will start working on
projects that may have been built some
time ago in which case you may need an
older version of python on your machine
to do that hover over your machine type
on the left hand side and click that
will take you through to a different
page and you have all of the different
releases that you can download so for
instance if i wanted to download 3.9.10
i could click this here and it will
download the installer and i could go
about and just install it in the same
way as we are now about to for 3.10.2
that's a little bit more advanced than
beginner but i thought it'd be
worthwhile just noting it down so the
installer is here and ready let's open
that
okay so it's giving me the option um let
me just zoom in a little bit there can
you see that a little bit better so it's
giving me the option to install now now
you can click that and it will go ahead
and it'll install python in that path i
don't find that very intuitive um i like
to keep python in my own path of choice
because if i want to download more
versions i know exactly where they are
and i can just flick between them as and
when necessary so we're going to go with
custom install and we are also going to
click the add python 3.10 to path
because if you're using let's say a web
framework such as django django will
need to look in your environment
variables and your path to understand
where python is on your machine so it's
important we click that okay let's zoom
out quick
so we will click that click on customize
and you can see we've got a whole bunch
of things ticked just keep them ticked
okay this is the first install that
you've done so let's get the
documentation let's get a package
manager called pip we'll be using that
later on in the course so keep that
ticked okay and keep everything else
ticked for now
click next and then we've got i'll zoom
in again uh we've got a few other
options here just keep it as is you can
see that the fourth one down says pyth
add python to environment variables that
is important we'll do that okay
so all we need to do is click on browse
and change the customize install
location so i'll go ahead and do that
and i like to keep my python versions in
my pc
c drive
and in here i will create a directory
called
python
uh
this doesn't want to contain right okay
we've already got one called python have
we we have okay great um
we will then go in there and create a
new folder and we'll call this
python3102
click enter so if i was to
install
python397 i'll create a file called
3.9.7 and i'll install all of the python
packages
and files and configurations in that
directory
so it keeps it all in its own little
container so you can keep flicking
between them okay that's why i do it
that way so we click that click ok and
you can see now where it says customize
install location it's now changed to
python python3102
okay
now we want to click install
there we go it shouldn't take more than
a few seconds but that's now going ahead
and it's fetching and installing all of
the python bits and bobs and adding it
to the directory that we just created
and to test to make sure that it is on
our machine present correct and working
as expected we need now need to fire up
what's called a command prompt on
windows now it's called a terminal on
mac but you
you fire it up on windows by going to
the search bar and just type in
com and it'll come up with command
prompt
mine looks a little bit different to
what yours would because i'll change the
settings yours would probably be black
but all you need to do is type python
you put python 3 or 3.10 if you're on
mac or unix
you put dash dash
version
okay actually because we've got the
py.exe file
installed from this install we can
actually reference on a windows machine
machine python with py
and that should still give us python
3.10.2
you can see that there you go happy days
so we've now installed python on our
machine we're now ready to start looking
at the interpreter we will then start
looking at things like text editors and
ides and things like that so let's call
it a day with this video and i'll be
seeing you in the next video
[Music]
so i'm on a windows machine so i'm using
a command prompt so if you are on a
unix uh mac or linux then you use a
different command to me when firing up
the interpreter or
using just general python commands you'd
use python 3.10 now i use python or py
the reason i know i use the command py
is because this paragraph here
i installed py.exe launcher
in the last video i put together which
we
used to install python on our machine so
when i'm on my command prompt and i'm
typing things such as p y dash dash
version
you would put python 3.10
version to do exactly the same thing oh
typo there but you see what i'm saying
okay so let's fire up the interpreter
with py
this is telling me the interpreter is
open and in interactive mode that's what
these
three great land symbols are telling me
saying give me some code i want to do
something with it
but before i type into it let's
understand what the interpreter is doing
so as i type python code into this
interpreter it's translating it into a
universal language called binary binary
is ones and zeros yeah in
like this
difficult to read you can understand but
this is the programming language that
software engineers used to use back in
the day when writing programs thousands
and thousands and thousands of lines of
ones and zeros
joe average could not just sit on a seat
and start coding it was a pain in the
ass okay so and it wasn't very scalable
so
from binary
the assembly language was put together
and this kind of streamlined binary it
allowed you to use um much more easier
to understand commands to do the same
thing but assembly languages weren't
transferable between machines so my
windows assembly language didn't work on
a different operating system okay so
then
high level languages were
designed okay and that's this took the
assembly language to the next level this
allowed programmers to write code in a
humanized way in an elegant way to
ascend and and then translate it to
binary okay so that's what so these high
level languages
php c plus plus you've got java and of
course you've got python right so these
languages allow us to code
in an elegant way and then things like
the interpreter will then translate that
into binary code so our machines know
what you're trying to do now i hope i
didn't just butcher that explanation but
i'll just try to break it down what the
interpreter's actually doing because
when i started i didn't get that
explanation i just wondered what the
hell i was doing i just started typing
away and it magically done something in
the background so i hope now you
understand what it is and how it works
but before i close this video off let's
just fire in some code and just see it
working so i can just put a simple one
plus one so integer plus integer in this
case one plus one if i press enter
it will then run that command and the
result is two
so we can go 10 multiplied by six so we
can use the multiplication operator
which in this case is a star press enter
and it spits out 60.
so that
is the interpreter okay all it's doing
is taking our um
code in this case python and it's just
translating it so that your machine can
do something with it okay so let's close
this video off in the next video we will
start looking at text editors and ides
so thanks for watching i'll see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]
okay so my browser's open on
microsoft.com on their visual studio
code page because we will be installed
in vs code in today's video
vs code is a text editor now we use text
editors because in the interpreter we
can easily write single lines of code we
can run scripts but it doesn't really
help us with things like syntax errors
and debugging
that's where text editors come into it
and also they will help us as a
developer manage things like directory
trees and hundreds of
files okay that's why we use text
editors they're apps that we can install
that help us
just do our day-to-day job now ides
which are integrated development
environments take text editors to the
next level they do everything that a
text editor can do
but with all the bells and whistles so
to help you with things like debugging
and deployment okay
i will be installing a text editor
called vs code because it behaves like
an ide because it has been called
extensions and it's fantastic in fact
the reason i'm installing vs code is
because on their own website they've got
a tool here
that helps you decide what's best for
you based on what you do okay so under
the languages platforms and workflows
you can click sorry you can click the
machine you're using then the languages
platforms and workflows you can click in
my case desktop python javascript and
it's telling me that the right
job for what i do or sorry the right app
for my job is download visual studio
code so let's go ahead and do that it'll
download the installer redirect us first
download an installer
and then if we open that it'll open up
the installer i will zoom in because
it's quite small on my screen here
okay so it's asking us to read the t's
and c's please do that it's always worth
doing that i've already read them so i'm
going to go ahead and click the i accept
the agreement
click next it will then ask you where
you want vs code to be saved i'm going
to go ahead and just keep it with the
default
it then asks you to um
what's this select start menu folder
just keep that as next it's fine then
it's giving you some extra options one
of them is quite important is telling
you to add it to your path so same as
installed in python let's get this added
to our path and environment variable so
that it's accessible and we know exactly
where it is on our machine
and then if we click next it will
summarize and we can then click install
should only take a minute or two but
it's now installing all of the files and
all of the configurations in the path
that it suggested
when it's done it asks us if we want to
launch bs code we will keep that ticked
and click finish and in a future video
i'll show you how to open vs code in a
certain directory as and when necessary
so
i already had an instance of vs code on
my machine and it's opened up in the
directory which is going to be the cheat
sheet for this course and you can see
that it's got all of the different
topics that we'll be going through but
this is bs code okay so if i just
zoom in a little bit
there we go we've got an explorer
here we don't necessarily need that open
um it doesn't really matter so we've got
an explorer tab or panel we've got a
panel here that we can actually write
straight into so if i open up a new file
here
and just put
hello with an extension py because
that's a python file that'll open this
up and i can write straight into it okay
but what is beautiful about vs code is
we can install an extension that will
help us with syntax errors
click extensions on the left type in
python
it'll give you a whole bunch of python
extensions now i've got this one
installed
it's called python and it's been
installed by over 50 million people
actually i looked at this the other day
and it was 49 and a half million so
there's a lot of people installing this
extension so not that
you gotta assume that 50 million people
can't be wrong right so it's good it's
going to help you with syntax errors get
it installed or select another one and
get that installed on your vs code
instance and it will help you with
syntax let's go back into the panel here
and also what's good about vs code it's
got a terminal built in so where i've
got my command prompt here
let me close that down i would open up a
terminal
mine defaults to cmd because i've
changed the settings yours might be
powershell but you can select the type
with this pull-down list click command
prompt
and then you can simply put py
happy days now i can type straight into
here one plus one
and you can see that that works and you
can see here that actually this is with
this under
underlying squiggle here or underlying
squiggle it's telling me that actually
that's a syntax error and that's coming
up as a problem and it's explaining it
here that's because we've got the
extension installed
so
that
is
done right we've got a text editor
installed on our machine we've got vs
code installed we've got textedit we now
can start coding in python in fact
whilst i've got this directory open
you can see that we're going to start
going through these files and talking
about each of the topics in detail using
vs code so that marks the end of this
video thank you very much for watching
in the next video we will install git
bash and the reason we'll install git
bash is because this repository is on
github and you need to clone it down to
get access to it on your machine so
thanks for watching i'll see you in the
next video bye
[Music]
so gear is a version control system and
with git installed on your machine you
can manage version control using places
such as github git labs and bitbucket
okay so it's important you've got git on
your machine i have already got 2.35.1
on my machine which is the latest and
greatest version at the point of
recording so i won't be following along
with this video because it gets a bit
clunky and it switches my video off and
it's just not pretty when you're trying
to watch and follow along so i'll show
you the steps get installed get git
installed on your machine and come back
to the video okay so click the link here
oh sorry right we are on git dash
scm.com okay that is where you'll find
git
and you need to click on the version of
win uh git for your machine type mine is
windows so click on download for windows
when you get redirected click on the
link that is um
the right one for your machine mine's a
64-bit window so i need the installer
for that i would click this here and
that will download the installer when
downloaded open up the installer and
follow along with the easy step-by-step
guide and that will get git on your
machine okay so now that you've got gear
let's open up vs code in the correct
directory or in your directory that you
want this to be
i want mine to be in my course directory
click here this is an easy way of
opening an instance of vs code without
opening and then scrolling and doc and
trying to navigate
type cmd
when your command prompt opens just put
code space period and that will open an
instance of vs code in your development
directory
so now we need to clone down so open a
terminal
from the drop down open up git bash now
you'll only have this option if you've
got git on your machine so that's why
it's important you've got git okay so
now we want to use the command git
clone and then after that we need to
dump in there the url of the repository
so in github
the repository that you want to look for
is github.com bobby dash decoding slash
python course for beginners this is a
public repository and all of the
documentation is in there okay so we've
got all of these different python files
so if you click code in the main branch
and copy this code here open up vs code
dump it in there
space full stop and that will clone down
the repository into your directory
it's asking me for passcode because i've
got an sh
ssh key
there we have it
okay so you probably won't get asked for
a passphrase
um
no bother so this is the um supporting
documentation so let's open up
uh one of the first ones we'll be
looking at numbers
so numbers.py this is the first thing
we'll be looking at
these are the sport documentation use
these as cheat sheets so at the end of
this course you can always refer back to
these files make your own notes it's
really really helpful i do use cheat
sheets still there's some certain things
that
i might not necessarily use on a daily
or weekly basis so i just need a
refresher so
that would be my advice save these on
your machine and keep referring back to
them so
that is the end of this video hopefully
now we'll be ready to start really
jumping into this course and start
looking at python code itself and we'll
be starting with numbers so thanks for
watching i've enjoyed making this video
i'll see you in the next video thank you
bye
[Music]
so i've got vs code open up on my screen
here in the file called numbers.p
there are a few of these files in the
sporting documentation that we cloned
down from github in the last video but
we're looking at numbers so we'll close
the explorer because i want to use as
much real estate as possible you can see
here i've got a terminal with the
interpreter up and running
okay that's what these great end symbols
mean
um you do that simply by um if we put
exit
ahead of myself there a little bit in
the terminal or command prompt just put
p y if you're on windows and there you
go there's the interpreter but we'll be
using the interpreter to take an input
and return an output so the input will
be a sum the output will be the result
that's what we're doing we're using it
as a calculator
in python we have a whole bunch of
operators that we can tap into
let's make that a bit bigger
we've got
the symbols that's the operator and what
it does the description here okay so
we've got plus is addition we've got
subtraction multiplication nice and easy
right basic stuff
division now that will always return a
float which is a number type we'll talk
about that in a second
so
10 divided by 4 would be 2.5
floor division is the same but returns
the integer version so 4 divide so 10
divided by 4 would be 2. so 2.5
remove the decimal and the 5 is 2. so
that's floor division
modulus is the remainder of 10
divided by 4 which would be two so
that's the remainder so four goes into
ten twice
the remainder is two so four plus four
is eight
the remainder is two that's modulus then
you've got power of so
star star
is if you put a five star star two would
be five to the power of two so five
times five
five star star three would be five times
five times five which would be one two
five
that's power of
you've then got assignment operators
we've got equals
okay you there are other ones we've got
equals equals got equals greater than so
on and so forth now if you go to
uh python's doc page
if you look up here we've got
docs.python.org
three slash tutorial introduction.html
that is python's documentation
to an introduction to numbers i've
extrapolated everything i feel is basic
stuff you can do a deeper dive on their
docs please feel free this course has
been designed around their documentation
so um
i wanted to give you the very very
basics okay
okay so i've got number types got
integers we've got floats integers are
whole numbers floats
are um
numbers with decimal places okay you've
then got fractions but again this is a
beginner's class okay so we'll look at
ins and floats today you've got some
built-in functions we're using round
today
so if we were to use round function on
this number here
you could pass through a number
and then pass through the amount of
decimal places you want and it will it
would
return the rounded version so for
instance if i pass five point six six
six seven da da da da da through to this
function here as the number
change decimals to two that would return
five point six
seven okay we're using div mod we're
also going to use what else power so
there's a couple of other functions that
we've got here that are built in to
numbers really really helpful div mod
returns a tuple of the result of the
floor division and
modulus
so div mod 10 4 would return 2 2.
we'll look at that in a second
lastly before we jump into actually
throwing in inputs and getting outputs
python is a really handy way of
representing large integers so four
billion which looks a bit hard to read
can be represented as this
four underscore three zeros underscore
three zeros underscore three zeros i
think it's a really handy way of
representing large numbers
especially if you're coding
so okay let's look at some of these
basics here
and we will dump them straight into the
interpreter so anything that comes after
a hash is a comment and the interpreter
knows to ignore it okay the comment is
for you
excuse me
so two plus two simple addition is four
five minus two is three seven times ten
is seventy simple stuff right
all we're using is the interpreter as a
calculator
then you've got division so 10 over 4
would be 2.5
okay
which is a float 2.5 floor mod is the
same calculation but rather than 2.5 it
would be 2 because it would disregard
the decimal place and 5.
10
modulus 4 would be 2
okay and then div mod would be 2 and 2.
because it's this sum and this sum of
ten and four
let's show you what i mean
go in here right click press enter if i
now
it's a bit hard when you zoom so far in
when you're doing a screen share to
[Laughter]
show you what we're doing here right so
10 over 4 is 2.5 10 divided by 4 2.5
10 floor division
over four so ten with floor division
four would be two because rather than
two point five you you're removing the
point five that leaves two
ten modulus four is four goes into ten
twice
whole okay that gives you eight and the
remainder of that sum is two
that's y is two and div mod which is a
built-in function is doing
floor division
and then modulus so 10 we're passing
through ten four and it's essentially
doing two calculations two and two
brilliant
again you can spend as much time as you
like adding these into your own
interpreter you can always add other
sums to give you a much better
rounded knowledge of numbers in your own
time but this is kind of a simple
walkthrough for you as a beginner
okay i'll now copy this these are fancy
sums so think of bodmas when you're
looking at these sums
so brackets other division
multiplication addition subtraction in
that order
and what will happen is
oh
let's copy this
copy
there we go so
it will do this part first because that
is the multiplication so 5 times 6 is 30
50 minus 30 is 20. it will do this first
because of the brackets
and it will do this inside the brackets
first because it's multiplication so
it's 15 minus 30 is 20.
20 divided by 4 is 5 which is division
so it will return a float
then you got 5 times 3 plus 2 so 15 plus
2 17 okay
i say fancy sum sums can get a lot more
fancy than that then you got 5
power of two which would be 25
and i did say earlier five multi um
power of three would be one two five
which is correct
so two to the power of seven is
one two eight if i remember rightly oh
it's more than that oh it is one two
eight but you can also use a built-in
function called pal
which saves the use of the star star i
don't know what's easier to read but two
to the power of seven
returns the same it's one two eight
then um variables so it's not really
numbers but you can assign anything to a
variable and today we're assigning
numbers to one so
60 is assigned to the variable width
we're using
the assignment operator
height equals
21. three times seven so width
multiplied by height
i think is one two eight zero
one two six zero there you go i was
tinkering with this earlier so um rather
than doing 60
times by 3 times 7 which is essentially
the sum you're assigning the numbers to
a variable and you're using the
variables to do the sum itself okay
which is all fun and lastly before i
close off this video let's look at this
so in interactive mode in the
interpreter the last printed expression
which is really handy gets saved to it
automatically saved to a variable
underscore so you don't need to assign
it at all it knows to assign it to an
underscore variable so we bop this into
the interpreter
okay
price times tax has now automatically
been assigned to underscore okay
so if i can now if i now do price plus
underscore
oh
let's just type in that'll be easy there
you go so price plus underscore is
113.0625
now that expression has been saved to
the variable underscore so you see how
that's gone underscore is inconsistent
every expression or the last one is
assigned to it okay
now if i use round
that's not liking that so i type it
round
underscore
comma two remember that function we
looked at earlier
there we go
round underscore so underscore is
113.0625
decimal places two
so it's 113.06
okay
so this is my whistlestop tour of
numbers okay there's a lot more to learn
there's fractions uh there's all of the
different operators you can do really
really fancy sums using numbers
please look at the documentation on
python there's no better place to learn
numbers than python
numbers page um this like i say this is
just all for beginners so
keep the support and documentation add
more notes as you find something else
that is interesting but that is the end
of this video thanks for watching i've
enjoyed making it and i'll see you in
the next video which will all be about
strings bye-bye
[Music]
so again i've got a vs code instance
open on my screen here in settings.py
which is one of the files we downloaded
or cloned from github
we look in the explorer here you can see
there's a whole bunch of other files but
we're looking at strings today so
python can be used to manipulate strings
which can be expressed in a few
different ways
they can be enclosed in single quotes
with double quotes so it doesn't matter
it is still a string if expressed in one
or the other way
now a backslash is used to escape out of
a string or a quote should i say and
that's really helpful in one of the
examples that i've got uh in a moment or
two um because there's certain words
that you use they say an apostrophe and
if you're using single quotes then you
can imagine that you're in a whole spot
of bother with that string unless you
escape out okay so python strings cannot
be changed they are immutable so you
cannot isolate a character in a string
and replace it with something else okay
you have to create a new string
altogether which is completely possible
we'll be looking at a built-in function
called len in this video now len is
really helpful you can use it on strings
lists dictionaries tuple sets and it
returns the number of items or
characters in any one of those objects
really helpful with strings so if we
called len on my name which is bobby it
would return five because bobby has got
five characters in it okay
strings have a whole bunch of methods
now these are really really helpful okay
so i've listed out all of the different
methods that you can use on a string so
for instance capitalize there you've got
a bit of space
so if i put uh
bobby as a string
capitalize would return
bobby okay as a string really helpful
method to use
and you've got a whole bunch of other
stuff here as well you've got case fault
sent account in code
um
well other examples so
that you got right at the bottom there
you've got upper so that would just be
bobby wood return
bobby is all uppercase okay so really
helpful
methods when managing strings you'll be
using them a lot
okay you now need to open up a terminal
and open up a
interpreter so i'm in windows so py
i've got my three greater than symbols
there so it's ready for an input so i've
got a few examples here that if i pop
them straight into the interpreter
we can see what's actually going on here
okay so
the top here we've got spam and eggs in
single quotes
as an input so the output is a string
spam x
doesn't has an apostrophe okay so we've
got single quotes single quotes because
we need to use a single quote in the
string you need to escape out using
backslash and it converts the single
quotes to double quotes and then you
return your output it doesn't with
double quotes
really helpful understanding the
backslash
or you could just write that string as
double quotes and you won't have any
problem whatsoever now in this example
we've got double quotes in the string
itself that haven't been escaped out so
of course what gets returned is that
whole string the double quotes within
the string are characters
the way you can escape out and use the
double quotes
in the string itself sorry would be to
use the escape and it changes the double
quotes to single quotes
that is pretty much the polar opposite
of the dozen example so it doesn't we
had single quotes we used an apostrophe
in that example we're using double
quotes and actually we want to use
double quotes in the string in which
case you need the escape
backslash okay
if you look at the documentation on
python if you're looking 3.1.2
on
docs.python.org 3 slash tutorial slash
introduction
that is their intro to strings so do a
deeper dive in there i've extrapolated
out a whole bunch of stuff
um hopefully that is just the basics
that i've got in my video here
okay so next we've got new lines so
new line is represented in python with
backslash n
okay and if we were just uh use the
interpreter it comes out as a single
string it just ignores the new line but
if you print it
from a variable it will pick up that new
line and print it as first line second
line in this example
so if i use this copy
pop it in there
so we're saving first line
new line second line into an s variable
if we just return s it just prints out
the the return statement it doesn't do
anything but if we use the print
statement and pass through s then it
picks up that new line
first line the second line that's really
really helpful when you're trying to
format
certain strings to a user maybe an api
message something like that
right
next we've got um raw strings so we can
use r for regular expression to print
out raw strings because you can imagine
a path here we'll have backslashes and
this example is a great one because
we've got our backslash n so if we were
to print that it's just going to come
out something silly because we know
backslash n is new line in a print
statement
but if we use r as a regular expression
you can see that you can see c sum name
has been done c sum and then it's
printed out this
but if we use regex then it's absolutely
fine okay string literals so you can use
three
quotes whether it be single or doubles
and that will print out
everything under that so it's sort of
like a comment so a comment is a hash
but it's a single line the string letter
will come can span numerous lines and
i've done that at the top of the page
here for my description okay
so that's what a string literal is
copy that
dump it in here and it will print out
exactly as you want it to be okay
then you got concatenated basically
glued together so uh if we use the
number three multiplied by un that would
basically do u n u n u n and then the
plus symbol the operator in this case is
concatenate and they'll glue u n u n u n
with i u m so that should
bring that in there you go
you don't even need to use the operator
plus if it's two strings put together
like that python knows what you're
trying to do and it would actually join
it together
the coding really helpful stuff
but that's really helpful when your
strings in a text or
parentheses there
um
span more than one line
python knows what you're doing and it
will just join those together okay
so
um
this only works for two literals though
not with variables or expressions so
we're going to have an error here
try and dump this in here
okay so it's it's basically because
we've got a variable and a string
whereas um what you need is two strings
so um prefix equals did and then you've
got prefix with that well you then need
to use the operator and then it will
work just nicely okay so the removing
the operator will only work when using
two strings
that's what i'm trying to put there
in indexing so strings sorry i keep
hitting my mouse button it's really
annoying
indexing so
we need to understand indexing for
things like strings and lists okay
and i love this i took it straight from
the python website but um
an index allows us to play with certain
characters in string based on where that
character is in the string by its index
so the first point in a string is zero
and the last point is in this case a or
minus one so you can reference the
string from the front so not one two or
you can reference it from the back minus
one minus two minus three
so when we're working with a word such
as decoding if we go word
square bracket
zero we're referencing the first index
of the word decoding which would be d
okay
let's dump all of these in my
interpreter and see what it spits out
okay
so so right so the word is decoding so
word index 0 that's the first as per
this um diagram at the top here zero one
two okay
word five would be
oh it's printing out little d so it's
not one two three four five so it's d
okay so you can see that that's working
you can reference so if you put zero
colon
two that will be include and exclude so
it's include
zero
one and exclude two which is d i
include 2 3 4 but exclude 5. that's what
that means okay
so b d c o
if you missed the first integer in this
expression it assumes you mean 0. so
that would be zero one exclude two which
is d i
if you move if you ignore the last
integer it assumes you mean the very
last or let's say minus one okay so that
will be everything from four to the end
and then we've got some other examples
there okay
so we've got minus so we're referencing
minus what minus two
to the end which would be ng
there we go ng and then you got you can
bring these two together so you can join
them together so it's everything up
until but excluding two and everything
from two everything to the end you join
into it brings together decoding
and then again you've got another one
here which is an example of bringing
that together okay
so that's indexing it's really really
really helpful so changing strings
so if we wanted to change
so referencing the d but assigning p it
says no no no no type our string object
does not support item assignment it's
immutable
so if what we
do is
have the string p
plus
word which will be including the first
so this would be everything from o
onwards
that will work and it will change it to
pid coding
or equally we can do this
d-i-d-d-i sorry d-i-d-i okay
so we are just manipulating strings
that's what we're trying to do and
demonstrate in this video
okay we're using lens so if we look at
bobby decoding which is the github
username
it's got 15 characters in that using the
length function really really helpful
function you'll be using that quite a
lot
handy built-in functions so when you
don't need fancy outputs but just want a
quick display of some variables for
debugging purposes you can convert any
value to a string with the
wrapper or the sdr functions so here's a
list of just some handy little functions
that you can you can use okay and here
are some examples of what you can do so
x y
y 400
what you can do is dump them in here
and that will just give you a really
handy representation of what you're
trying to achieve same with sdr it will
just change everything to a string
okay and then you've got
which there we go so let's give those
examples there
so we've got format okay so this there's
a bit of an explanation here in python 3
you can use the f string which is f
followed by two um
quotes and then you can use placehold
placeholders to add variables but you
can also use format which is valid for
python two and three and what we're
doing here is we're doing a print
statement and we're adding placeholders
that's what these squiggly brackets are
so it's placeholder and placeholder and
then dot format which is the method and
it goes in order so the spam will be
injected into this placeholder and eggs
will be in that placeholder and equally
in the second example here we're just
changing them around so nor is the first
item and one is the second item in this
tuple
and that will just change it around eggs
and spam okay
so
that's my whistle stop tour of strings
there is more to go in and do a deeper
dive on python's website here but do
that in your own time do a bit of
bedtime reading okay but that is the end
of this video i'm
glad that i put it together i hope
you've enjoyed it and i'll be seeing you
in the next video thank you bye
[Music]
okay like always i've got a visual
studio code open on my screen in the
list.py files so this is just one of the
pages in my supporting documentation
that we claimed down from github a
couple of videos ago
we don't need the explorer open we want
as much real estate on a screen here as
possible so we'll be manipulating lists
today uh a list is a data type so
there's four different data types that
python knows of lists dictionaries sets
and tuples i'm going to do a video on
each so i don't need to explain explain
the difference in them
except for lists are written as a list
of comma separated values or items
between square brackets okay so a list
will look like
this okay that would be considered a
list in
python okay
now lists are mutable so
unlike strings that are immutable and
tuples immutable a list is mutable you
can change and alter the items in lists
so you can identify a certain item and
you can replace it with something else
okay so they're mutable
which is really really helpful
i have also added on all of these pages
if there's any methods that are
associated to a particular let's say
data type or let's say numbers or
strings or anything i've listed those
methods in
the files themselves so lists have got
methods such as append which allows you
to add an element to the end of the list
you've got count extend index reverse
sort so on and so forth
when you have a bit more time outside of
this video just have a tinkle of lists
and just play with these methods they're
really really really really helpful
okay so into the basics we will need a
terminal open and we will need a python
interpreter
in interactive mode okay we've done that
100 times in this course already so all
you need to do is fire up three great
end symbols shows me that it's ready for
an input
so this is a basic list and we're we're
assigning that to a variable called
squares okay so
dump that in here and now we can access
squares by just doing that and it will
just print out in the interpreter the
list okay so that is a list
in um
python okay we've then got it scroll
down indices so this is exactly the same
as we went through in the string
i haven't changed this to a list but
essentially imagine that this is a list
you can change these to square brackets
if you like
but essentially
each item in a list you can reference by
its index so in this case this is zero
this is one this is two this is three
and this is four in the same way as in
this string you've got zero one two
three and four you can reference it from
left to right
naught one two three and four or you can
reference it right to left which would
be minus one two three four five okay
same as string but understanding
indexing is paramount in python is
really really helpful so if we put
squares zero it will return one
squares minus one would return 25
minus three so slicing when you use a
colon that syntax means include
everything from minus three
having the missing integer means to the
end it assumes you mean to the end so
minus three would be naught one two
three so it would return all of that
okay so if we copy all of this
and we bump that in here
there you go
there we have it right okay so creating
a list copy this is quite handy
sometimes
just
open bracket close bracket with a colon
in the middle now do it an outright copy
of the list you can assign that to a
variable and then you can
change that copy as much as you like it
doesn't affect the original
it's a handy way of creating a copy
concatenation so same as strings you can
glue things together you can glue
strings together you can glue lists
together okay so if we take the variable
squares
we can
glue a second list to it and then what
you've got
is a much bigger list
oh sorry so all right okay let's go um
squares underscore two equals
and then we'll dump that in there if we
then put squares underscore two there
you go
oh
my typing's fantastic so squares remains
the same because we didn't assign it to
a variable then i did sign it to a
variable called squares two and this
then becomes this
okay so that's concatenation that is
essentially gluing two lists together
which again is really really helpful
right you can alter items so unlike
strings where you can index
the character but you can't change it in
a list you can so i can find one by its
index and i can then replace it
so in cubes you can see we've got 1 8 27
65 that's incorrect okay that should be
64. so 3 to the power sorry 4 to the
power of 3 equals 64. so we need to
reference this by index
which in this case is index 3 so it's
not not 1 2 3 or you can go minus 2
so that could just be -2 it's the same
way you're just referencing it from a
different direction
and you can
then put equals 64. so you're
referencing the item in the list and
replacing it with the new number and
then we'll print cubes again
okay so now the new list
is one eight twenty seven sixty four one
two five so it's mutable you can change
the items by indexing them and then
assigning them with the operator equals
and that's the same way as we do it in
dictionaries actually you reference the
key using this method with the key name
and then we use equals to assign a value
okay so it's the same as in dictionaries
list method so we've got a pen so with
cubes we can now append 216.
let's just do that
we'll use a pen to do an operator of
seven to the power of three
and then if we put cubes
you can see that list is just grown by
two because we've appended two one six
and then three four three okay so we're
using the method
append
adds an element to the end of the list
this is your cheat sheet you'll be
referencing this page a lot in the near
future so keep adding to it if you find
other methods that are really helpful
just keep adding to this cheat sheet and
save it and you've got it as reference
point in the future so length we look at
this in lists it's sorry in strings it
just returns the amount of characters or
in this case items in a list so that
should return four because we've got one
two three and four
okay
four really really helpful
then you've got nesting
so nesting we've got one list a b c and
d we've got another one one two and
three if we assign both of them within
another list to a variable x
x is a list that contains lists
show you what i mean
okay so you got
square brackets that contain
one list
and a second list hopefully that makes
sense so to get
this list from its parent list you
reference x with
index 0 because this is index 0 this is
index 1.
so x
0 would return the first list
so then if we want to get
b from this list it would be x zero and
then index one so we're grabbing that
list from that list we're then grabbing
b by that integer and that's what we're
doing here so spend some time
understanding that it's really really
useful
especially with lists but especially
with dictionaries as well because you
might be working with dictionaries or
json and in which case you're
referencing keyword after keyword after
keyword just to
access different values especially with
api calls and things like that so it's
really really helpful to understand that
list comprehension now this is a little
bit more advanced than what i would
normally put in one of these kind of
courses but
uh because we're using a
control flow so we're using a for loop
so list comprehension allows us to write
this piece of code here in one line
essentially so i'll just gloss over it
quickly
so
don't worry about this we'll go through
control flows in another video but using
this piece of code we're creating a list
i won't go through the ins and outs of
what we're actually doing and how we're
looping through but we're creating this
list here okay
by using this one line of code which is
called list comprehension you don't need
to use multiple lines of code to create
that same list you can just go
with one line and lo and behold it
creates exactly the same list but with a
much easier
syntax okay we'll go through
loops a little bit later but list
comprehension is massively powerful so
please read up on it if you go to python
docs on this page which is
docs.python.org three slash tutorial
slash introduction
it gives you a rundown of
numbers strings and lists if you scroll
down to the bottom near enough to the
bottom here
we've got
where are we there we go 3.1.3 lists so
it goes into great detail there and if
you do a deeper dive in the python docs
you've got a lot more to read about
this comprehension okay
so
go back in visual studio code we've then
got the final bit of this
video which is built in function which
is called list so this function will
convert
um
in this case it's a tuple into a list so
it just takes one object and it converts
it or tries to convert it into a list if
it can so this is just a tuple and a
tuple is defined similar to a list but
instead of square brackets it uses just
standard parentheses
this function is converting that into a
list
so we'll change that to square brackets
okay so there we go
bobby at decoding.com okay so
that's my whistlestop tour of lists like
i said this is geared towards beginners
you've got supporting documentation this
is your cheat sheet that you've got on
your screen here
read up on lists play with lists and add
to this cheat sheet as and when you find
something interesting you can keep
referring back to this as long as you
want
two three four five years down the line
in your career and you may find
something useful okay
so that marks the end of this video
thanks for watching i've enjoyed putting
it together i'll see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]
okay so we're looking at tuples today
this is my visual studio code instance
opened up in the tuples.py file that is
contained within the supporting
documentation that you can clone down
from github okay there's loads of files
in here
the structure of this course is that i
will just walk you through and talk a
little bit about tuples from this form
because this is kind of a cheat sheet if
you like for you to use and we'll give
you a rundown of what a tuple is and
then we'll give you some
examples of code so we can actually
start understanding how to work with
tuples
so um python knows of four compound data
types lists tuples sets and dictionaries
okay on the documentation it talks about
lists they're tutorial for beginners
documentation but they don't really talk
too much about sets dictionaries and
tuples so i thought i'd put three videos
together to help you out and also put
the documentation together so you can
reference it
okay so tuples are written as a list of
comma separated items surrounded by
parentheses or brackets unlike lists
which is square brackets okay
now tuples are immutable which it sets
it very very uh very much aside from
lists that are that are mutable okay so
you can't assign
items to a tuple where you can in a list
okay so that's an important difference
between the two
two balls have two methods available
they've got the count method and an
index method so you have a tuple dot
count will return the number of elements
with a specified value and tuple.index
parentheses returns an index of the
first element with a specified value
okay they're the two methods that we
have on two ports
okay so let's jump straight into
um a few code examples
open up a terminal and fire up an
interpreter and what the first line here
is an example of what's called tuple
packing we will also talk about
unpacking of a tuple in a few moments
time so what we're saying here is t
which is a variable with an assignment
operator of equals
then we've got three items so we've got
an integer integer and a string we're
saying here that we want to assign or
pack these items to a tuple name t
because that's the equivalent this
expression is the equivalent of doing
this okay but you don't need
those parentheses to do it because it's
a tuple so we can then
access the first item by its index of
zero
if you don't know much about indexing
i'll talk about that in a few moments
time and then we'll just print it out in
the terminal in here interpreter
okay so t
three items
referencing the first index which is
this one here if we then put t
one would get the second
item in the uh
total but you can see here just by
printing t
do it again
that shows you that you don't need to
put the parentheses to pack a tuple okay
tuples can be nested okay so here we've
got u so we're assigning t which is a
tuple we've got a trailing comma and
then we've got a fault we've got another
tuple here we're
essentially um
using the packing of a tuple to create a
one tuple with nested two balls that's
really what we're doing here so if we
put u equals t
trailing comma tuple
and then put u you can see we've got the
open parenthesis here is the first tuple
and then we've got one
item we've got another item
okay
you can't assign
to a tuple it'll come up an error type
error tuple object does not support item
assignment okay that's a demonstration
of a tuple that is immutable you cannot
assign
values to items in a tuple where you can
in a list and a dictionary and a set
so
they can contain
mutable objects however so let's create
another variable with v
and here if we put v you've got a tuple
with two lists in it so we can now go v
first so this will be the first list and
then we can say
first
index that'll be one
equals
two
okay if we now put v two two three so
although the
tuple itself is immutable
the lists that are mutable that are
within the tuple can be altered you can
assign values to items in the list okay
so that's the example i've got there you
can see that we looked at the first or
zero index zero index which is this here
is the one so this becomes the zero
index of the tuple and that is the zero
index of the list and we're equals using
the um
assignment operator
two so that that's why this becomes two
two three three two one okay
indexing
i've talked about this in previous
videos but i love this it's really
really helpful uh it just shows that if
you're referencing a string or a list or
a tuple from left to right then the
first item in the list or the two pull
the string or so on and so forth is zero
second one is one two three all the way
up so let's go from left to right if you
reference it from right to left
then it's minus one minus two minus
three minus four so you have options of
actually identifying certain characters
or items in objects by their index
really really helpful
so we can get the
zero index of t
which we know is one two three four five
we can get the last index of t with
minus one
but we know there's only three items in
that tuple so we can also reference the
last item with
two because two is also the same index
in this instance is minus one
hope that makes sense
trailing comma
okay let's get this example in
here
so we're creating a variable with an
empty tuple called empty
and then we're creating
let's
i had a test in the last time i did this
let's do that again
do apologize
okay so an empty variable so empty
becomes a variable that contains a tuple
which is empty itself
singleton has just one string with a
trailing comma
that's how singleton is going to be
created as a tuple that's how we know we
do it you only need a trailing comma
when a tuple contains one
item
so we then use the len function to
calculate the length of empty and we
know that there's nothing in there so
we'd expect it to be zero singleton has
one so if we print singleton it says
hello with a trailing comma okay
there we have it
and we've then got unpacking of a tuple
so at the start we said t equals and we
added integer integer and a string we
can do the opposite of that and create
three variables i do apologize
create three are variable variables and
equals t and what that does it does the
complete opposite so it takes each item
from the tuple when it signs it to
its
um corresponding variable in order so x
becomes index zero one and two so we
expect that to be one two three four
five
so on and so forth
so let's go ahead and do that
copy
we don't need that
okay so it's unpacked it so x becomes
one two three four five we've got five
four three two one to y and then z
becomes hello that is called unpacking a
tuple which is really really helpful
when you're working with tuples you see
that in quite a lot in code examples
then you've got built-in functions so
we've got um tuple as a function so two
port open parenthesis and basically in
this example here i've just got a list
that contains a whole bunch of string
and when you add the function tuple to
it it converts that list into
a tuple okay
so although it starts off as a list
by using the tuple function it converts
that list into a tuple and now that is
immutable okay we can't assign anything
to at so if we went
x
1
equals
that
it will say you can't do it whereas
beforehand i would have been able to
because it was a list okay then you've
got tuple comprehension which is very
similar to list comprehension except
you're
you're using um
the tuple function to convert that into
a tuple that's you know it's quite it's
just an example of how you can um use
the tuple function
okay
so that is
it so if i stick that in here look it's
just an example
okay so just use normal list
comprehension and can use the tuple
function to convert it into a tuple
so
i won't go into great detail about what
that's doing because we're using the
ethics it's the an example of
a control flow which is a for loop and
you use list comprehension to change
what could be five lines of code into
one easy to read line of code that's
list comprehension for you in a nutshell
but we'll look at that a little bit
later it's kind of an advanced or
intermediate kind of topic so let's not
worry about that so that is tuples thank
you very much for watching this video
and i'll see you in the next video we'll
start looking at sets okay thank you bye
[Music]
okay so we're looking at sets today you
can see here i've got a vs code instance
open in a file called sets.buy if you
don't know where this is or how to get
hold of it then a few videos ago we
cloned down a supporting documentation
repository for this course so get your
hands on that and you can follow along
but the structure of this course and
these videos is that i'm showing you and
explaining what certain things are and
then we've got some code examples to
walk you through nice and easy so let's
talk about sets so python knows of four
compound data types which i'll keep
repeating because i say that at the
start of all of these videos and it's
lists dictionaries tuples and sets today
we're talking about sets
if you look at their documentation they
not only talk too much about sets in a
beginner's tutorial so i thought i'd do
a video just to walk you through it and
help you out so sets they are an
unordered collection with no duplicate
elements like a dictionary a set is
defined with curly brackets so
sets are really handy they're kind of
like list except a set
cannot have
duplication
okay so a list you can have duplicate
item after duplicate all day long not a
problem whereas a set it cannot it has
to have
unique items so that's what's kind of
where it stands apart from lists now
i can talk about this uh in a future
video perhaps but when you use um the
set function combined with lists it's
really really helpful to look at all
unique items within a list and do a
comparison and do some analytics really
helpful stuff so i use sets all the time
anyway so a set a set is mutable it's
like a list a set is mutable you can
assign
values
to items in a list you can't in a tuple
okay so that's important to understand
and also sets come with a whole bunch of
handy methods okay so the add to add an
element to a set you've got clear
removes all elements from a set so on
and so forth i'll let you read through
those methods in your own time but
like with a lot of objects and bits and
pieces in python
read up on the methods because they can
save you a hell of a lot of time because
if you don't know of the methods you
will try to code that in yourself and
you might use 10 or 20 lines of code to
do what essentially one
little snippet of code can do for you in
seconds okay so read up on those are
really really helpful so code let's open
up a terminal and fire up a python
interpreter
there we have it so all we'll be doing
is copying the code and dropping it in
here okay
i'm hoping it's big enough for you to
read okay so here we go
basket equals and then we've got curly
brackets curly brackets now when you're
just glancing at code it's easy to get
confused with a um
a set and a dictionary because the
dictionary is also curly brackets but
what is different
in a set is that it's just comma
separated whereas a dictionary has key
value pairs which are comma separated
okay so looking at this i know that this
is a
set but you can see here we've got apple
and apple
which is duplication okay so if we were
to
then print basket what it does it prints
the variable without the duplication
okay does that make sense so although
we're assigning this set to the variable
python in the background is taking that
set and it's removing the duplication
okay but there is some funky little
ordering that they do
which you then have to sort
but we won't come on to that in this
tutorial
but when you're tinkering with
compound data types you will find some
weird and wacky stuff that goes on so
you'll have to get quite creative
so we've then got orange in basket so
fast membership testing
okay so we're saying does
basket as a variable contain the string
orange okay which we know it does
because we've printed it out here so
we've got orange so we're saying orange
in basket
fast membership testing
really really helpful
crabgrass says false so it's just a
boolean true false but really helpful to
understand okay and then you can
demonstrate set set operations on unique
letters from two words okay so we're
using set as a built-in function
so we've got a set
and we've got b set
so we've got two variables so if i put a
and i'll put b
okay you can see here that d
b c r a so it's remove the duplication
of b which remove the duplication of a
and so on and so forth
so you can say
a minus b
okay
so we're now comparing sets against one
another and we're using these operators
here so these are all of the different
operators that we can use to compare
these are called set operations
okay so we've got the bar
so let us in or b or both
really helpful when comparing data in
these compound data types letters in
both a and b so we're using the amber
sensing symbol there and then we're
using this operator
to say letters in a or b but not both
okay that's what that operator means
okay
so there's always
do your research on sets
when you're looking at sets and lists
and comparing the two and doing some
sort functions on them it's really
helpful to understand what we're doing
here because you can actually get a lot
of output with very little input by
using these methods and operators okay
so in your own time have a good read up
but this is your cheat sheet so if you
find something interesting on python or
in a youtube video then add it in your
cheat sheet you can always reference
back
i do all the time by the way then your
set comprehension
so in the last video i just did list
comprehension and used the um the tuple
function but you can actually use
squarely brackets here just to go
straight into set comprehension
there we go
we've got a
there we go so we're saying xrx so this
is control flow so like i've said in the
previous two videos so using
comprehension it allows us to create a
set or a list or a tuple
by doing a loop of a variable or another
list or so on and so forth dictionary um
but you can do it in one single line of
code and it's much easier to read than
let's say four or five lines in a for
loop okay there's an example in my list
video and then you've got built-in
functions so we've got um set which we
talked about a moment ago so we've got
bobby bobby at decoding.com creates a
set object
there we go so again the ordering is all
squiff you know bobby bobby at
decoded.com i'm sure there's some logic
as to why it comes out like this but
we've got com at decoding.bobby but
essentially it's done the work so it's
gone through that in this case tuple
it's converted it to a set and removed
the duplication so it's in the
background of python it's doing that
work for you like i say when you're
coding hundreds and hundreds of lines of
code it's
so good that we can use these functions
to really minimize what we're doing and
get the same output
low amount of input same amount of
output that is the key and that marks
the end of this video so thank you very
much for watching i've enjoyed putting
it together join me in the next video
we'll start looking at dictionaries
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
so we're looking at dictionaries today
you can see i've got vs code open up on
my screen and it's in the
dictionaries.py file in the supporting
docs for this course please please
please clone down for my github
repository if you do that which we've
gone through in all of the previous
videos you will have a directory that
looks like this it's essentially a a
directory tree of python files that can
be your cheat sheet so when you're
learning python always reference back to
these really really helpful okay so
we're in dictionaries.py structure of
these videos is that i'm going to just
talk about what dictionaries are give
you some code examples we'll fire up an
interpreter and we'll just put some code
in and have a little play okay so
like i've said in the last three videos
python knows are four different compound
data types now we've got lists tuples
sets and dictionaries i love
dictionaries they're like a powerhouse
you can store data
really really easily
they're very similar in a lot of ways to
json
so you reference values by keys and
they're just really really helpful
you'll be using them a lot so
dictionaries are great for storing data
values and it's in a key value pair so
i've got an example of a dictionary here
but we won't put it in the interpreter
because we'll be doing that in a second
or two but essentially
like a set a dictionary is referenced by
curly brackets but unlike a set we have
key value pairs separated by colon
so we've got
a key which is uh like a string in this
instant and we've got a value so it's a
string so it's a key value
then it's separated by comma so it's e
dictionaries are great in text editors
when they're expressed in this way so uh
each key
separated by a space with some white
space here and then you can have your
value it's much easier to read so we've
got the second item here which got uh a
key and then you've got a key this is a
string third one we're actually using a
list as the value
and then the last one we've got a
dictionary as a value okay so you don't
just have to have strings you can have
lists sets you know dictionaries you can
use integers strings whatever whatever
you like as the value itself okay
dictionaries are mutable this means that
item values can be changed which is
important okay
we've then got
this which i like i've enjoyed putting
these together right so um lists sets
tuples and dictionaries all have a bunch
of methods we can tap into now when
you're coding these methods are really
really helpful they can if you don't
know of them or you've never heard of
these methods and you might find
yourself doing line after line of the
line of code just to do the same thing
as this little snippet can do
essentially it would be dictionary dot
and then you could have clear open
bracket close bracket and that will
remove all elements from a dictionary
okay
all of these methods tinker with them in
your own time open up a text editor have
a play run some code and you will become
uh fluent in these very very soon but
you've got a whole bunch of them you can
tinker with so do that
i urge you okay so let's open up a
terminal and a
um
python interpreter
okay and then we'll dump in some code so
we'll put the dictionary that we were
talking about a moment ago in here
okay and we've assigned it to some dicks
so if we put some dicks
the interpreter will express the
dictionary in this way which is
hard to read like i said in the last
video about sets um sometimes you can
look at this and go oh curly brackets
it's a set or it's a dictionary and get
it wrong because you
for it to be a dictionary it's key value
key value items separated by commas a
set is just item item item okay but look
you'll get used to it after a while so
this is key value separated by
separated by a colon but each item is
separated by a comma so it's key colon
value comma key colon list is the value
comma okay
you'll get used to it
we've then got
um this so this will return an error so
if we were to unlock a list so if we
were to reference an item in a list or a
set or tuple we could reference the item
by its index so the very first one item
in a list suit set or tuple you can
reference by index zero if i do that on
the dix it will come up with an error
because you don't reference
items in that way you've got a key error
okay there's no such key as zero
you need to reference key value pairs by
a key okay so in this case we could put
sum dict
key error
sorry not here a key so we're
referencing a key
and the value is a value and this one we
put a key for we should get a dictionary
back
there we go because we're then
referencing this
really helpful but you manage
dictionaries in a slightly different way
is what you would a list hoopla set
you've then got creating addict copy
this is one of the methods i was talking
about
really helpful if you want to create a
copy of a dictionary you can then assign
that to a new variable and you can alter
it you can
change some of the values and then
you've got just a an absolute copy of a
previous dictionary and the previous
variable is safe and you haven't got to
worry about that
so
again that's quite a helpful method for
you so you've got alternative so we can
like a list we can use the assignment
operator and assign a new value to a key
value pair
okay so add the cube of six
that's a hangover
i used a lot of the same
code examples across these um but some
dicks so what we're doing there we're
assigning a new value to there and then
we're printing out the
uh the value for key a key which is now
a new value okay so we're assigning a
new value to a key value pair
use again len which is the len function
the length function and that should
return in this case four because we've
got four items in a dictionary
we can then use the keys
method we'll return all the keys
okay then you've got the values method
we've sent all the values okay so
if you want to do um some analysis of
the keys of the values or key value
pairs you can do that by using some of
these methods like i said
spend some time going through them um so
what we got your keys returns a list of
containing the dictionaries keys you got
pop that will remove the element with
the specified key okay so you can
specify the key pop and it will remove
it from the dictionary
okay so there's all these different
fancy things you can do so spend some
time going through that you've then got
dict comprehension which is the same
very similar
to um list comprehension that we've
looked at in the last few videos so
again i won't spend too much time about
control flows because we'll be covering
that in a future video but um
list dictionary two port and set
comprehension
essentially means that you can create a
dictionary using just one line of code
it's much easier to read
do your research on list convention
list comprehension and dict
comprehension outside of this tutorial
i've got this example here so you can
actually see what it's doing or at least
understand the syntax
but if we do this
there you go we're creating a dictionary
with a key of two value four key of four
value 16 and so on and so forth okay
so we're basically looping through this
tuple and we're creating a key
and then a value of it'll be value to
the power of two that's what we're
getting for 16 36.
okay so i'm not glossing over
comprehension they're really really
powerful but this is a beginner's course
and i don't want to get bogged down in
some of the bits and pieces that you
don't necessarily need to know at this
point i'll do a future course that would
be an intermediate level and we'll start
looking at comprehension and and
things like that
tips and tricks then we've got built-in
function dict so this is on all of those
forms so you can just
we can check so the dick function will
take
um keys and values and it will just
convert them into a
addict so it creates a dictionary object
so if we use this
there we go so we've got
a equals one so it's a1 and you've got
b2 yeah so it's converting that syntax
using the dix function and it converts
that into a dictionary which is really
helpful right it saves you how many use
comprehension saves you having to
manually write that in your code base so
i hope i've done dictionaries some
justice um dictionaries are like i say
it's a powerhouse we use them all of the
time i certainly do and uh when you
become a master on dictionaries they can
really really be helpful when you're
writing code when you start tinkering
with um
modules such as jason and they're so
closely aligned it's really really
helpful to understand so that marks the
end of this video i hope you've enjoyed
watching it i've enjoyed putting it
together and i'll see you in the next
video where we'll start having a look at
control flows catch you later bye-bye
[Music]
okay so if statements really looking
forward to this one i use if statements
all of the time fantastic okay i've got
vs code opening if statements dot py
which forms one
file from the wider supporting
documentation for this course
download or clone it down from github
please do that if you're learning to
code it's always good to have a
reference point and you can always
reference back to these files as and
when required when you're just
scratching your head a little bit so
please please please do that okay let's
move on so let me talk about if
statements a little bit i will try not
to butcher my explanation of what an if
statement is and then we'll look at a
code example okay
if statements sort of conditional
statements right now you and i as human
beings we kind of work through this
logic
naturally in our day-to-day lives okay
the an if statement is just a way of uh
taking that logic and putting it into
your program or into your code okay so
an example of that logic would be
walking down the road or down a pathway
and you want to cross a road okay so you
don't just die out across the road and
run across the road you're going to get
hit by a vehicle right it's not going to
be pretty instead
you
use some logic okay you you
approach the crossing or you get to a
point where you want to cross the road
and you stop you check to see if cars
are coming are there any cars coming yes
or no if yes
you don't cross if no then you may cross
or you might then say well is it safe
for me to cross if yes cross if no
check again loop through that process
over and over until you are completely
safe that you are ready to cross that
road okay it's kind of one example of um
logic that you use in the real world you
want to make a cup of coffee do we have
milk yes we do make the cup of coffee
okay logic and an if statement would
take that logic and allow you to use
that in your program into your code okay
probably butchered that a little bit but
that's if statements they're fantastic
so think of an if statement is a way to
check to see if conditions are met if a
condition is met do something else do
something different
that's kind of what i was trying to
explain
elif stands for else if okay so you do
if then you'll have else if now an elsif
is optional and then at the end of the
statement you could have else which kind
of a catch-all
that's optional too an if statement only
needs to consist of the if statement
itself okay
both l f and l optional okay no it will
be defined
or i will be sorry i can't read i will
be defining a function in this demo
we'll talk about functions in a later
video but just
bear with me okay you may or may not
know what functions are but this is
using a keyword def
we're calling it number play
that's the function name and we've got
parentheses where we're passing through
a parameter or an argument
um followed by colon and then this
essentially
forget the function that statement that
you're seeing on the screen here that is
the if statement but i'm just putting it
into a function so i can make calls
against it so let's have a little look
so all of this here is optional because
it's lf life lf you don't need any of
that you don't need it it's optional
but if
it's the start of the if statement so x
so x is the variable here so imagine x
is 10
an integer okay so we're saying we're
using this expression here which is less
than so if x
is less than zero so it's a negative
number so minus one minus two what we
say is x equals one oh sorry zero
it's been a long day and then we print
negative changed
to zero so that will appear in our
terminal or in our python interpreter
elif so else if x equals equals
so this is um checking to see if x is
equals to something so we're saying if x
equals zero
print zero
if x equals one print single
else so this is the capsule so all other
numbers so that could be four hundred
and sixty seven so if x equals four
hundred and
it would just print more okay so that's
the catch-all so by pulling this
function
if i pass through negative one we would
expect to see this
zero
then the third one down here would be
single and the last one would be more
that could be like i said that could be
whatever number it would just print out
more okay
so let's get that in our terminal
let's open up py
uh python interpreter and let's dump
this
function there we go this may work i
might need a little bit more white space
but let's have a look you can never be
too careful with there we go so that's
now working right so number play
number play is now a function it looks a
little bit messy in interpreter when you
see these three uh periods there that's
basically means that it's expecting
another line because an a function very
much like an if statement has a colon at
the end that means that the the actual
code appears in the next line after some
white space
okay which could be four spaces or one
tab
so function is in there
now let's call it now we'll call number
play and we'll call it with an argument
minus one
negative change to zero okay so let's go
and we'll change that to zero
printing zero because
this was not met so is there a car
coming down the road
yes there is
is it safe
across the road okay
i want to make a cup of coffee is
if there's milk in the fridge
is there sugar in the cupboard so on and
so forth okay that's kind of what we're
doing sorry i'm really um butchering if
statements here but i'm having fun so
okay and then this last one here there
isn't actually a number deleted it uh so
we can put it
let's just say more okay
so um that
is
just a single example of if statements i
could do so many examples of if
statements i could i could make this
video last
an hour long i don't need to this is a
beginner's course i'm just trying to
show you what an if statement is what
control flow is how your mind should
work when you're writing code that
contains if statements why why and where
to use them there is actually another
video i'm going to put together about
match statements which are pretty new to
python 3.10 which kind of take if
statements to the next level they're
kind of like a switch statement in other
languages
but
if statements are kind of entry level so
one example
after this video
don't watch anymore open up vs code and
just start
coding if statements and have a play you
will have so much fun you can really
have some fun with her statements so
actually do watch the rest of the videos
please do but i'm just saying have a
play with this statement sorry okay so
that marks the end of this video okay
thank you very much for watching i
really enjoyed putting it together
i'll see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
okay so my vs code is open up on
match.py because we'll be looking at
match statements okay
this file is one of the supporting
documentation files so get them cloned
down from github there is your cheat
sheet so you can always reference back
to this whenever you see fit but i have
pulled this a paragraph from python's
own website and this uh explains exactly
what a match statement is but i will
then demonstrate
match statements because i don't think
this is really kind of beginner proof so
structural pattern matching has been
added in a form of a match statement and
catch statements of patterns with
associated actions
patterns consist of sequences mapping
primitive data types as well as class
instances
pattern matching enables programs to
extract information from complex data
types branch on the structure of data
and apply specific actions based on
different forms of data okay so that is
the official description of a match
statement
but i'll show you what it all means okay
so a match statement takes an expression
and compares its value to successive
patterns given as one or more case
blocks
so
we have a class in this demo so a little
in the code examples here i've got a
class which we haven't touched on yet i
will be putting a class video together
as part of this course so don't get too
caught up in the actual class itself
so let's look at this code so i'll open
up a terminal and a python interpreter
but essentially let's look at this
function so it's httpr tpp error and
we're passing through an
argument called status
then we've got a match statement with a
colon so everything after that codon is
the match statement and everything after
the case colon is a case
to be matched or compared against so
we're passing status through to match
and then we're comparing the status
against this case statement
does it match yay on a
does it match yay or nay so on and so
forth now at the bottom here we've got
an underscore now that's a catch-all
if the
um previous three cases blocks in this
instance are not met then this one will
met it's kind of the else statement in
an if statement so let's have a look
let's get this in a terminal in a python
interpreter
py and we'll dump that in
here
okay so if i was to call http error
and pass through 400
we know that that will match so the
status which is 400 will match this case
statement okay so if we do it again
pass through 404
found an error
which you'd expect because it's me in
that case statement
418 is i'm a teapot but if we were to
pass through 401
something went wrong with the internet
that's the k that's the catch-all okay
so that's kind of a very very basic of a
match statement you could write that as
an if statement of course you could and
so if status equals equals 400 so on and
so forth
but match statements come into the row
when you get a little bit more complex
and it takes a lot less code to get the
same output i'm all about less input
same output or even more output
so this example is using the bar to as
an or statement so if status is 400 or
401 or
they're not allowed four one eight is
i'm a teapot and then a catch all again
okay so let's go http error and this
time we'll go 400
not allowed because it's part of the
case statement here again if we go 403
it'll be exactly the same because that
is part of this is an uh kind of a
an or statement so 400 or 401 403 so if
we put 418
that's me matching the
i'm a teapot and then if you could put
500
it would say something went wrong with
the internet so that's a little bit more
advanced than the first one so we're
stringing them along and using or
patterns can look like unpacking
assignments
and can be used to bind variables so
point
is x y tuple so point here is a tuple of
x y okay so let's
copy that
oh sorry
there we go this i'm sharing a screen
i've got zoomed so far in that it
becomes very difficult to highlight so
i do apologize
let's dump that in there
okay so we've now got a new http error
function
and then we'll pass through we'll call
point tuple
sorry we'll add
these to point tuple okay
so we'll do the first one
so we go
um
http
error
tuple
origin okay so that's what we're doing
there so we're just changing the
variable 0.2 port so this is a zero zero
so that's meeting this
okay
what we're then doing is we're actually
assigning y so this is what the patterns
can look like unpacking assignments can
be used to bind variables so we are
binding
in this point the uh index one of the
tuple two variable y and then we've got
variable x and we're using that in an f
string okay so let me
show you what that means um
if i'm butchering the explanation of
this then you can have a play outside of
this video of this video
so now if i call that again
what we've done here so it'd be easier
now to explain so by passing through the
tuple zero comma one two three
and calling it we're then getting this
printed out and the reason we're getting
this printed out is because
we are assigning
the
first index so which would be um in this
case in a two port it'd be zero and one
we're assigning that from point to a
variable y
does that make sense and in this case
we're assigning it to x
so x becomes the first point in the or
the item in the tuple and y becomes the
second i am in a tuple
i may have butchered that as well but um
let's have another go so this will be
assigning one two three to the variable
x so if i now call
there we go x is one two three
and the last
the last one is x y
okay so that is matching
this one here
so x y so we've as we're assigning um
the first item to x and the second one
of y is me in this case so it's printing
out this this f string which is
basically i'm using placeholders to put
the variables in but um again you can
look into that i haven't i didn't go
into that in any great detail in the
string video
but that's just one way of handling
strings with f strings and placeholders
okay so else we've got a capsule and
there's a value area not a point okay so
that is a little bit more advanced match
statement
and lastly we've got this one okay so we
will copy
all of this
to our interpreter
okay
so we've got a class here and we're
using the um
we're importing data class from data
class and we're using that as a
decorator and essentially what that's
doing is adding a whole bunch of methods
to the class point one of them is um a
dunder in it you've got the wrapper
you've got all of these different things
don't worry about that i've used that
because it's made this class a lot more
powerful without the need to actually
code more
we'll talk about
classes and whatnot in a in a future
video we've then got where is so this is
just a function again we're pointing
through point uh sorry we're we're
passing through point as an argument and
then we're matching point against the
different case statements okay and you
can see here we're actually calling the
class point so this is where match
starts really coming into its own
because trying to do this in an if
statement would be an absolute pain and
it will be very very difficult to read
but essentially the case statement is
now a call on the point class
so if we now pass through
we'll call the where function and pass
through the point class with zero zero
we're getting origin okay does that make
sense
so we're calling the function we're
passing through an instance of the class
with a
two arguments zero and ten
and it's just giving you all of it's
matching the cases we don't necessarily
need to go through this but what i've
essentially given you here is a cheat
sheet on match
it's very very new there's not many
videos out there i've probably just
butchered match but what what you uh
what you've got here what you've got
here is just some very very basic
to intermediate examples of how match
statements are differentiated between if
statements okay so you can
you are still
matching you're still checking um a
parameter or an argument against a case
or a statement and if it meets then you
do something very much like an if
statement in that regards but you can do
so much more and when you get used to
them you can write some pretty
complex match statements that are very
easy to read which is important so okay
that's my video on match statements i
hope it was clear and concise please
please get the supporting documents from
github and you can have a plate in your
own time
but
the important one is this one here about
classes because you'll be using that
quite a lot when you get more advanced
thank you very very much for watching i
hope you've enjoyed it i hope it's been
useful and i'll see you in the next
video thank you bye-bye
[Music]
so my visual studio code is opening up
on the loops.py because we're looking at
for loops we're looking at while loops
today so controls control flows um this
file is part of the support
documentation that you can clean down
from github please do have a look at
that
and um let's have a go of explaining
what loops are and i'll give you some
code examples that we can actually
practice on
so python's four statement
iterates over items in a sequence so it
could be a list a set a tuple dictionary
or a string and it iterates in the order
in which they appear in the sequence
okay so it will literally from left to
right
if you to then sort that list for
instance whatever the result of the sort
is it would then iterate left to right
okay so it's important to know that so
the built-in range function comes in
really handy when you want to iterate
over a sequence of numbers or a length
of numbers or a length of an item
as it generates arithmetic progression
so the range function can just take one
integer and that is the stop
argument okay so it has a start a stop
and a step okay if you don't pass a step
sorry a start point it will assume you
mean zero
so the energy that you pass through to
range is always the stop if you pass
through a third integer that would be
the step okay so a start is the value of
the start parameter
zero if you if you
fail to pass it through value is a start
and the step is
how many steps you want to do i've got
some examples of it that will that will
kind of
um hit that one home
but then we've got a very ex basic
example of a loop so we're creating a
list here so it's got cat's got window
and then it's got defense straight okay
so we've got three items in the list
okay
four
is what we use when we want to do a for
loop so we want to loop through each
item in this expression and it is this
in this case you could use a string but
this is a list so it's cat
window defense rate okay
and then we're assigning it to a
variable now that very can be any
anything you want
it's a variable so
i thought when i first started coding in
python or code in general that that
variable had to be w because words
starts with w it doesn't you can call
that horse
house
parrot
bobby whatever you want every time you
loop through that list
the the item the resulting item is
assigned to that variable so it can be
whatever you like okay so the first loop
would be cat
w
is assigned
the string cat
so when we then print w we're printing w
which is cat and the length of that
string which is three so the result will
be cat
three
the second loop would be window so it
would be window
six and then you would have defense
straight which is i think it's ten or
eleven so be done defense rate and then
the the length of that string so okay
let's dump that into a python
interpreter
there we go dump that in there
there we go so like i say cat three
window six and different r is 12. so the
length was 12. okay so that's what we're
doing there very very basic but the for
loop like i said at the top you're just
looping through every single loop you're
assigning what is found as an item or a
character whatever the case may be
you're assigning it to a variable you
can then do something with that variable
you can print it you can do a sum on a
number you can assign a variable to a
key
uh value pair and a dictionary whatever
you like that but you're doing a for
loop
you can then
nest an if statement in there and do
something based on a condition you can
list and match statement in there based
on a case statement
the world is your oyster okay so
create a sample collection so let's have
users what are we doing here
create a dictionary
called users okay so we've got quinn
active eleanor inactive john active so
this is a dictionary that contend
contains users and their status active
or inactive
okay
what we've then got is um iterate over a
copy so we're making a copy of users
okay so we're making a copy of that
dictionary remember that was a method
that we looked through
in the dictionary video that i did a few
videos ago
so four so for all for each user status
so so you work with dictionaries in a
for loop in a in a um set or a tuple or
a list or a character for it's just one
variable but because we are looping
through key value pairs
you need to express it in this way so
for each key value in this case we just
call it you can call them a key value
you can call them user status in this
case i like to use key value
doesn't matter so for each user status
so user status user status user status
in
a copy of users dictionary dot items so
these are the items so each item in the
dictionary
okay so what this expression here is
basically saying
that's one item
so we're looping through that
but we're assigning it to quin
active user status next item eleanor
inactive next item john active i hope
i'm kind of explaining what this means
this is a dictionary so we look for it
slightly different is that essentially
what i'm saying then i've got an if
statement so we've got an if statement
in here to say that if status
yeah so that's the variable so if status
in this case active equals equals
inactive
do something
in this case we're using the delete
function this will actually delete
users
user so we're referencing
the item by the keyword which in this
case will be quinn
so if the stat is inactive
well that condition hasn't been met so
it won't do anything so it does another
loop so we'll do another loop the second
loop eleanor if status is inactive
delete it so we will delete that because
that condition was met and then we'll do
a sec a third loop if john is active we
won't do anything so
the resulting
copy of users because this is a copy of
the dictionary will just be
two items quinactive john active okay
okay so if we go users
there we go
so that's exactly what we would have
expected so the inactive user has been
deleted from the dictionary that's what
we've just done
okay so create a new collection
so the new collection is an empty
dictionary called active users
so this time we are going to do a for
loop over users items so this is the
original dictionary
it's not a copy
and this one this time what we're doing
is we're saying if they're active
then
add
the key into the empty dictionary
with the value status so so we're
creating a new dictionary okay so
if doing the same for loop
except we're now checking that if the
user is active if the user is active
then we're creating a key value pair and
we're adding it into the dictionary
that's how it works if it finds the key
it will use assignment and it will
assign the value
to the key value pair if it can't find
the key it will add a new key value pair
okay
then we've got range so let's have a
little tinker
okay let's dump that in here so for i in
range five print i
what's that done
ah that's really really helpful okay so
for i in range five so remember we've
just we've just put one argument in the
range function remember i said that the
start would be assumed to be zero and we
haven't used the step so the one integer
we've passed through is the stop so
we've added five the first iteration of
that range is always zero when we're
using um indices so it's zero one two
three four that's four loops
of the range function
it's where it's really helpful
then what we can do is the start stop
remember so if we do two integers it
starts stop if we do three integers it
will be 0 10 3. so let me walk you
through this because this is interesting
so this is a start stop say the first
one is five
and then it stops at ten remember ten
would be nine because it's
if we did from zero to ten it'll be zero
one two three four five seven eight nine
so because we're starting at five it's
five to nine yeah get that
and we're using the list function to
then convert that range into
a list
we've then got
north 10 3 so start at zero
finish at nine so it's um sorry finish
at ten so it's not one two three four
three to nine so yeah we've got ten
integers naught to nine but we're doing
steps in three
so it's only show every third step or
every step of three
in the range so it starts at zero then
it's one two three then it's
four five six it's seven eight nine so
that's where the step function comes
into it and then you've got another
example using negative integers okay so
start at negative 10
finish at negative 100 in steps of 30 so
it's 10 minus 10 so
30 40 minus 50 60 70. okay
it's really helpful to know
so we then have mary had a little lamb
and we're assigning that as a list to
variable a
and then we're saying for i
it's a copy
so let's see what we've just done there
see if i can explain it
so for i so remember that variable could
be anything we want so for bobby in
range len a so that's the length of a
that would be one two three four five
so
remember we're and we're adding len a
into the range function so that's
that'll be an integer of five so for
range five so zero one two three four
there the five in range yeah print the
variable which will be mary had a little
lamb followed by
a
integer
so sorry i is the
i is so it's not one two three four so
it's nor and then we're returning the um
index
naught from a
that makes sense so this is the list
and the zero index is merry the one
index is had and so on and so forth
have i got that in here
i haven't let me open up
lists
let me show you there we go that's what
i wanted to show you so indexing i was
losing myself that indexing is really
really helpful there's a little diagram
here of of what it means to a string or
a list so the first item in the list is
zero index zero one two three four so
the first loop would be range zero
in the list would be mary and so on and
so forth okay so we don't need list open
so that's what we've done there and then
we've got sum range
four and that oh
some
range for
six okay
so what that's doing is um naught four
so it's not one two three so it's zero
plus one
plus two plus three equals six that's
what that's doing okay so it's loot sum
itself is looping through
the response of range four and then
saying zero plus one plus two plus three
equals six that is what that's doing so
i've given you a whistle step tour of
four loops or looping and conditional
statements in python i hope it's been
beneficial um
spend some time doing it so you now look
if you've been following along with this
course we've gone through if statements
match statements we're now going through
four loops we've gone through strings
list dictionaries tuple sets and
everything in between
now you're starting to get enough tools
in your toolbox to actually start coding
so please have a play reference this
document
outside of this video and just start
tinkering start programming okay so for
loops very very important and it's
hugely hugely helpful when you're
programming so this marks the end of the
video i hope you've enjoyed it
i hope it's been useful and i'll be
seeing you in the next video thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
okay so loot clauses today we are
looking at these now because we looked
at loops in the last video so loop
clauses is a natural progression from
that
visual studio code has opened up on loop
clauses dot py which is one of the
files in the supporting documentation so
clone that down it is a cheat sheet for
you to use so
let's talk about what loop clauses are
so python has a few statements of
clauses that we can use in loops they
include break continue else and pass
okay so loop statements may have an else
clause it is executed when the loop
terminates through an exhaustion of an
iterable that's for a for loop or when a
condition becomes false with a while
loop but not when the loop is terminated
by a break statement
so what does that mean as a beginner
it's difficult to understand so i've got
some code examples to walk you through
it okay
so this is a little bit more complex in
terms of a for loop so i'll try and walk
you through it okay
so
we'll put this in an interpreter as well
but this little statement here it's for
loop so we know range we're passing for
a start and a stop so 4n in range 210 is
the equivalent of saying 4n in this
little bad boy
so let's say it's a list so 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight nine so the first iterable is two
so the first time it does a loop it
assigns two to the variable n
keep that in mind
the second for loop so every time it
does a loop it then goes through this
part of the code okay this part of the
for loop okay so
this is for x in range two so a starting
point is two and the end point is a
variable n which we know is two because
that's the first one so range two two is
the equivalent of
a list that looks like that it's got
nothing in it okay so
um
it hasn't got and
x becomes nothing essentially it's
nothing right so there is nothing there
is no loop to be had
so
um
when we then do this if statement so if
n e
n modulus x equals equals zero well the
comparison isn't there because you know
you're comparing one against something
that isn't there equals equal zero so
that isn't false that condition is not
met so it does else
print statement i'm a prime number the
second loop is a three so this range
becomes 2 3
okay
so it then compares
that statement if it's
matches so if modulus n x equals equals
0 then it prints this statement here so
n
equals x and it's got a little string of
star then it's uh prime sorry it's floor
division nx
okay
so let's have that in our we've learned
all about floor division in numbers
right at the start of this course so you
should understand what we're doing here
so copy let's go terminal new and do
this
and dump it in
and what do we have there we go
so we expected 2 to be a prime number
because the condition wasn't met we
expect three to be a prime number
okay
and then it's four so the print
statement is four equals two times two
okay so it goes through that's what
that's doing it's a basic kind of for
loop was for loop with a for loop with
an if statement
so it's not basic at all
but we've got a little break statement
here so it prints out and then it breaks
okay so that for loop is finished so it
does the loop again so that's what the
break statement's doing
okay so continue statement so four and
i'm in range 210 okay so if num modulus
two equals equals two then do something
and it continues so this will continue
with the next loop okay so this is
another example
so it's just doing something slightly
different
so found an even number or an
odd number found an even found an odd
found and even found a nod right from
the two through to nine
then you've got a pass statement past
names are really really useful when
you're coding you might write classes or
functions that you need to call in
another function but you don't want it
to do anything because you're not
actually at that point of the code yet
you might be testing something
pass just means that it does nothing it
doesn't break or anything like that it
just allows you to
i can call my past class and it won't do
anything
okay
so this is an example of a function
you can add pass and i can call that
function so my
pass
def
okay it doesn't do anything because it's
just got a pass statement if it didn't
have the pass statement and it'll come
up with an error
actually it will show you in the text
editor here that you can't do that it
just doesn't let you do it so
that is clause loops again like with
this course i'm explaining what they are
i'm giving you some code examples all
that have been extrapolated from
python's own documentation for you to
read up in your own time and have a
tinker and kind of understand what i'm
doing or what python is doing i have
tweets some of them
but yeah that is loop claus i hope
you've enjoyed this video that is the
end of this one i'll see you in the next
video thank you bye
[Music]
okay modules today so it won't take long
to explain what modules are so before i
jump into it my vs code is open up in
the modules.py file
you can reference this whenever you like
it look at it is your cheat sheet but
you can get the support and docs from
github so um
all of that will be in the description
okay so modules so in python we're able
to write a long program and save it as a
module this is known as create a script
we're able to import modules across
modules
and into the python interpreter right so
what you don't want to do is write a
function
numerous times
what's the the best situation is to just
write it once and do not repeat yourself
the reason for this is because if your
function is incorrect and not working
correctly you need to debug it and if
you've got it
multiple occurrences of a function
across your project you need to debug
all of them what you need to do to
create one function and import it as a
module to your other application or
other
file in your project
so do not repeat yourself dry that's
what this is you may see that a lot in
your career
python
python standard library can be found
here they've got a whole bunch of
modules and fancy stuff that you can
import and take advantage of please look
at that at your own time we've got it
here in modules have a look at this page
and it look it talks about different
modules so import fibo
um
which is the fibonacci module there's
loads and loads of different modules you
can import but we're not going to look
at those today we're going to look at
our own that we've already created
so in the last video we were looking at
functions and we created a function
called demo func
in the functions file so that's a script
that we can import so if you look here
i've got from functions import demo func
now that will print out some
gobbledygook loads of twos because it's
got some other functions in the file but
essentially
with this line of code here will allow
us to import
that function so we can call it and pass
it through to these functions
let's get that
open up a terminal open up a
interpreter we dump it in there okay
so we've imported demo function yeah
it's printed out a load of twos because
we've got some functions in there don't
worry about that um it just now means
that we can access demo func so we can
say my int
equals demo func
and we'll pass through
28
okay so my int
now becomes 32 because that function is
taking an integer
addition adding on 6 and then returning
the new calculation so we're expecting
32 but what we can do we can now pass
that through to my funk one so we can
say my
funk
will pass through my
int
my funk what am i talking about it's
funk one funk
one
my int
there we go i do apologize okay so
you can see how we're importing a module
and we're using that module to interact
with other functions now we can import
func one into another module
does that make sense we you know you can
it's so important to make sure that your
code is as dry as possible do not repeat
yourself it is really important
so we've then got funk two so um funk
underscore two is that right funk
underscore two we won't we won't use the
demo funk this song cause this is
actually yes we will we'll go my int
and this is um this is giving us the
power of so my in this case it will be
32 to the power of
16.
oh wow look at that that's a big number
but that's a good explanation of modules
okay they're like i say so python's uh
standard library can be found here on
this page so if you look here on zoom in
oh it's not working it's not liking that
yeah there you go docs.python.org three
slash tutorials modules.html that's
where you'll find their standard library
or
documentation about their standard
library their
link to the library is
oh where is it let me crash that out oh
there we go
can you see that on the screen yeah
docs.python.org three dash library so
actually let's open that
in the browser
there we go so you've got a list of
everything in here okay so text position
services we've got date time which is
which is a great one so you'd say import
in the terminal
py so you'd say import
json
you say import
date time
or you can go further and say from
daytime import
um
i think there's delta no there isn't
there is a date time actually there you
go from daytime input daytime so these
are different functions and classes and
stuff within those packages so have a
good read up on all of these they're
fantastic
again like the methods in lists and
things like that when you really
understand this it can save you lots and
lots of time when you're coding
so that marks the end of this video
hope you've enjoyed it hope it's been
beneficial and i'll see you in the next
video thank you bye
[Music]
okay so we're nearing the end of this
course now we're looking at classes in
the next video and we'll look at a small
bit of programming a little api that
we'll write
that comes after this which is all about
exceptions and errors so my vs code is
opened up on errors.py this is your
cheat sheet you can clone this down from
github always reference back to this is
really really helpful as a programmer so
python has at least two distinguishable
kinds of errors so you've got syntax and
you've got exceptions okay as a noob
you'll be getting a lot of syntax errors
you'll need to talk look at colons after
functions and if statements and loops
you need to look at white space loads
and loads of problems but that's where
text editors are really really helpful
so look at my text editor video get one
installed we've got vs code in this
course
syntax errors
as you become better you'll be know
what the errors are sorry exceptions are
and you'll know how to handle them so
i've got all of the exceptions here so
you've got name of exception description
about what it actually means okay so
we'll be
having a look at some of these we've
already seen some of these during this
course but some at the bottom here
you've got type error you've got name
area you've got zero division error okay
so
work through them when you've got a bit
of time but we've got here some examples
of code that will be coming up with an
error okay so if we go p p y here
dump in some code this will be zero
division because 10 times one over zero
is zero division raised when the second
operator in a division is zero
you've got four plus span multiplied by
three well spam doesn't exist so we've
got name error if i put spam equals two
it now exists so we don't get the error
then we've got a string plus integer
doesn't like that okay but if we go two
plus two it will like that there are
exceptions so now we need to look at how
we can handle exceptions so we've got a
little while loop here in my example
let's get that dumped into the
interpreter and see what's going on so
we've got a while loop so while true you
do a try and accept statement
so i haven't talked about trying to
accept statements
you can read up in them on python docs
but we've got one in here so essentially
it's trying to run a piece of code
but we accept that if any of these
exceptions occur when running the code
we print this okay
so this this code could say anything
really but basically we're trying
something we've got a break clause there
and we're accepting if these exceptions
occur then we do something so this is
how you manage exceptions so if we were
to run a
try and accept on the code earlier we
could say if there's zero division error
occurs then do something else you can
just print a fancy statement okay so we
put five in here it won't have an error
okay but if we would find an error then
it will do this it will print oops that
was not a valid number try again
okay so then we've got
a function
try this fails so we say this
fails
division error okay so one over zero
division error but if we
stick it in a try accept statement and
bang that in here
it's calling this fail so try this fail
so we
we're calling the function and we're
accepting zero division error okay and
because we're accepting that we can then
say what happens in this case we're just
doing a print statement handling runtime
error division by zero
good so the try and accept statement has
an optional else clause which can be
present must follow and accept clause
is useful for code that must be executed
if the tri-clause does not raise an
exception okay so if a
final finally clause is present finally
clause will execute at the last task
before the try statement completes the
finally clause runs whether or not the
try statement produces it as an
exception the following points discuss
more complex cases when an exception
occurs so
let's get this little function in here
okay what have we got
see if we'll get it all on the screen so
okay so we've got a function called
divide and we're passing through two
positional arguments x and y okay so it
must have two arguments so we're trying
result equals x divided by y so that is
what we're trying that's the little bit
of code we're trying to run but we're
saying except
if we receive a uh zero division error
then we just print that we get type
error must be an in
if we else print result is result okay
so result equals then finally we print
executing
executing final finally clause tongue
twister so that will be printed anyway
okay so if we now pick up those uh
commands
and dump them in here
you should see
an example
oh i didn't like that
i do apologize let's pick this up copy
delete that and let's dump them in
okay so the first example
divide two one the result is two okay
because one is an integer above zero so
we don't get the zero
and what does it say so the result is
two so this actually it tried it okay
so result equals x over y
two
zero
that is a uh zero division error so
we're getting division by zero then
we've got
uh strings instead of integers it's
printing out must be an integer
so they're the three times we've called
it but you noticed every time
we get executing finally clause that's
because this is run every time it tries
okay so this is the finally clause and
that's what we're talking about
in here okay so that
is a let me just save the changes i made
that is a whistle stop tour of
errors and exceptions i hope this made
sense uh it's really really helpful
you'll find a lot of this when you're
reading other people's code people have
been coding in python a lot you'll find
a lot of this type of stuff so try to
understand it read up on the exceptions
on the python website understand what
they do and what they are and how to
handle them and you'll be good to go
that's the end of this video i'll see
you in the next video where we will
start to look at classes or certainly
i'll try to catch you later bye
[Music]
okay so looking forward to this one
because classes are the cornerstone of
oop or object-oriented programming in
python okay we looked at
functions a few videos ago and i said
that look at a function as a container
you have some script
and what have you when you save that
container you can call it and you give
an input you get an output okay you can
be doing some fancy stuff in the
function but essentially it's input and
output class goes so much more further
than that it gives you the ability to
bundle data
and functions together they are a
powerhouse okay
and unlike any other data type in python
okay so not you can store data in
dictionaries and lists and what have you
but classes gives you the ability to
store data and give it functionality at
the same time so
if you look at vs code on my screen here
i've got to open on cluster.py which is
one of the files in the support and
documents that you can clone down from
github this is your cheat sheet so
please do that it's massively helpful
when you're coding and looking back
forget certain things this could be your
reference point so please do
i've extrapolated a whole bunch of data
from python's own docs which are in
docs.python.org slash three slash
tutorial slash classes they go into
great depth about classes objects names
namespaces inheritance based classes
instance variables class variables and
everything in between okay so a bit of
bedtime reading for you
this course in this video is all about
beginners and helping you get started so
you can start tinkering and coding
so this is very um
very much geared towards beginners and
i've just extrapolated what i think is
what you need to know to start
so classes provide a means of bundling
data and functionality together creating
a new class creates a new type of object
allowing new instances of that type to
be made
python classes provide all the standard
features of oop the class inheritance
mechanism that we'll look at soon allows
multiple base classes
a derived class can override any method
of space class or classes and a method
can call a method of its base class with
the same name that's all about
inheritance it frames it very very well
but i'll walk you through that in a few
minutes
simplest form of a class definition
looks like this so you have a class
keyword followed by class name colon
then you have a bit of white space in
all of this now these are your methods
and class variables okay
so we'll look at that in a second
like with a function you must
save or you must define a class before
you can make or before it takes any
effect so let's look at some of my class
examples here let's open up a terminal
and a python interpreter so we'll dump
this
in the interpreter quickly so we've got
my class available so class
keyword then you've got my class
colon and then you've got some of this
the first line here is text literal i
would urge you
urge you to add a text literal to all of
your classes because if you're looking
back at a class that you wrote years ago
or somebody else's code
they may if they haven't got a text
literal there's no way of knowing what
the class does without really doing a
deep dive
where you can call a magic method called
doc and it will tell you exactly what's
going on mine's very simple but you can
put whatever you want in there it could
be 200 lines if you like
you then got a class variable which is
accessible to all instances of a class
which i'll give you an example of in a
second and then you've got the f method
just a we're just calling it f we call
it anything you like but that is a
method for this class that can be called
okay and it will just return a string
called hello world so we can now call my
class i and get back
the integer one two three four five we
can call
f and get a function method
okay and then we can call
the magic method doc
to get the string literal okay so you
can call
double underscore
double unschool on any class and it will
turn the string literal if it has one
so let's go ahead and instantiate this
class and assign it to a variable x so
the class is now instantiated and we can
access it using a variable x so again
we'll go x dot i
i'll move my mouse x dot i and we have
access to one two three four five which
is a class variable
now if we go x dot f but this time we
have parentheses
it will pass it will bring hello world
the reason is bringing back hello world
is because we are passing through self
let's talk about that
so
we pass the methods instance object in
as the first argument of all methods
so x dot f which is what we called here
is the equivalent of saying my class dot
f
and then passing through x
okay
self has no special meaning in python
the word self doesn't it's just it's
normal convention to do so so in this
class we're passing through self so that
is i said we're we're instantiating all
of this to x
and then the first argument in the
method is x itself and that's how we can
and that's how we can access that method
and call that method okay
i hope that makes sense being seen we're
doing it again here so we're expanding
on our class
let's get that in here
and talk about it text literal no change
but we're now using a new magic method
or dunder init method called init and
we're passing through self which we do
because we pass through the instance
itself or the object itself
and then we're passing through a
positional argument called my int
and it has to be an integer okay so if i
didn't have this in there you could pass
through anything but it won't like it
because we're actually using an integer
as a sum
so that's what that's doing
and within that method we are assigning
my integer to a
instance variable called self.i okay
so that is only accessible to the
instance itself
so whereas the first example i was a
class variable this is an instance
variable and then with the f method
we're just doing a quick sum so new
variable equals
we get any integer that we're passing
through as a keyword
positional argument and we do we're
doing a sum which is the power of 3. so
if we pass through 4 it's 4 times 4
times 4 which is 64. and we're returning
new
so let's instantiate the class to x
again
now x dot i
is four it's not one two three four five
now because we passed four through as
the positional argument
okay
now if we go x dot f
is 64.
okay so we're calling this method
it has access to self.i because we're
passing cell through as the instance so
x
is accessible in f
self die does that make sense
i hope it does
so we're passing the instance through as
the first positional argument is doing
the sum and it's returning the new sum
which is 64.
good
now let's talk about adding an attribute
so we can add an attribute to our
instance called counter
it's not in a class we're just adding
this
to the instance of the class so now we
have access to x dot counter
which would be one
if we were to do a little while loop
just on the sum
so while x dot counter is under one we
do something
and then so we're changing counter to
another number and every loop it just
checks is it unten is it under 10 is it
under 10 oh it's over 10 now stop that's
what a while loop is doing
so essentially i'll put a um a
description here so the first loop
returns 2 because it's 1
multiplied by 2
and then x becomes two so it's two times
two is four four times two is eight
eight times eight is sixteen and at this
point it hits the loop and says ah
sixteen is above ten so stop
so loop then stops so the fifth loop
does not happen so we know that x is 16
down here
so if we print x
it'll be 16.
but now we can delete that attribute of
the instance x by using del
now if we try and print it again it just
won't like it okay
it won't like it but what we can say is
attribute or we can call it
attribute two oh we didn't assign
anything
yeah x attribute two
and then we can
find out yeah and we can do another sum
on it but then we can go del
x dot
attribute do and that will delete it
and then we don't have it okay so once
we've instantiated a class we can then
add attributes remove attributes really
really helpful
and you can't do that with dictionaries
or anything like that you can you can
add data to dictionaries and because
they're mutable you can um change values
and things like that but with classes
you get so much more that you can tinker
with
so now let's talk about in a little bit
more depth instance variables
so you can actually understand it a
little bit more let's create another
class called dog
now what we're doing is we're a class
variable that's available to all and
then we've got instance variables that
are only available to the instance so
when we instantiate the class we will
have access to a name and tricks
variables and then we've got a method
called add trick and we pass through a
trick and it appends it to this list
of the instance variable not the class
variable
okay so dog kind the class variable is
k9 so every instance of this class will
have a variable called kind and that
will be equals to k9
so let's create an instance assign it to
d
okay in instance
i'm going to assign it to e
so d has the name fido and e has the
name buddy because we're passing through
a positional argument called name so you
have to pass a string through
actually you know you don't even pass
anything you like through but we could
do that
oh
we could do that and it has to be a
string
okay so let's save that so e
kind
d dot kind will be exactly the same this
is a class variable but e dot name
will be buddy
d dot name
will be friday because that is specific
to the instance now we can go one step
further
we can assign a trick to d
and it'll be specific to d
and we can assign another trick to e and
all this is doing is taking that string
and it's appending it to the instance
dix list
which is an instant stick
sorry list is not a class list
that was a class list and we added roll
over and play dead then both instances
will have access to those tricks in this
case so we now put d oh
we don't want that we want it down here
d dot trick you can see
sorry
d dot trick
those tricks sorry
there we go d dot trx roll over e dot
tricks
play dead
so we can then add another one
to e
e tricks it's now got two in there d
tricks still got the one because we're
only
using instance variables okay so that
makes more sense so we're instantiating
more than one class and we're tinkering
with those instances of that class so
let's talk about inheritance
oh let me just come back in here i've
made some changes
inheritance so
a class can inherit from other classes
okay so base classes now you can it can
inherit from numerous different base
classes indeed a base class can then
inherit from another base class now this
is really handy when you're trying to
write clean code because what you don't
want is duplication of methods across
numerous different classes it's good to
have a base class that has common
attributes and methods that you can use
elsewhere and you can then inherit from
a in a derived class from a base class
so think of it as kind of a
a tree so the top you have a base class
which two clusters can inherit from or
two or more and then so on and so on and
so forth okay so for instance this
example here this dog class
could inherit from the
animal class
because a dog is an animal you could
have a class called cat
that would also inherit from the animal
class now that animal class could have a
whole bunch of methods in there
that um are useful to
um derived classes
i've got another example here so so
actually this is an example of a derived
class so you've got the class name and
you've got a bracket and all of the
classes that it's inheriting from
okay and then again you then state your
the same you do in a normal class
but remember a derived class can
overwrite the methods of its inherited
classes for instance the dog class might
have a special method or a special way
of handling the
um tail method
that is different to a
frog that doesn't have a tail or loses
its tail when it goes from tadpole to
frog
it's quite a good
explanation of
methods and overwriting them okay so
execution of a derived class definition
proceeds the same as for a base class
when a class object is constructed the
base class is remembered this is used
for resolving attribute references if a
requested attribute is not found in the
class the search proceeds to look for
that base class or in that base class
this rule is applied recursively if the
base class itself is derived from
another class
so it keeps looking and looking and
looking recursively derived classes may
extend or override methods from their
base classes okay so
really really really helpful and it
allows you to write really clean code
otherwise you could have one class that
is crazy long and then you're
duplicating some of those methods in
another class that is crazy long it's
best to have two smaller classes a base
class that they both feed from
okay so i've got a couple of classes
here that kind of walk you through that
so let's open
and dump all that in my
interpreter and let's see if we can walk
through this
okay so we've got mapping that is our
base class in this example private
variable example so check out double
underscore update this is called name
angling there's a bit about name
mangling in python's own docs so have a
look at that
um it's uh that's what that's the
example actually they use in their own
docs so but we don't necessarily need to
talk about that in great detail at all
in this
um explanation it basically means that
this update can appear where it appears
in the class um
it's done without regard of syntactic
syntactical position so um normally you
can only access certain uh variables
because they appear above them so
but
because we're using name angling we can
access update no matter where we put it
so um
do a deeper dive of that and python docs
that's a bit beyond um beginner level so
mapping's got a
special method called in it
and we've got items list and iterable
as
instance variables we then got an update
method
so for item in self iterable and we have
access to self iterable because it's an
instance variable we then append it to
this empty list of the instance
then we've got a class called mapping
subclass and we
which derived is a derived class and a
base class in this case is mapping which
is the class we've just talked about
here
so this inherits from mapping
but you can see here we're
overwriting the update method okay so
although we've got it in here
this mapping subclass has actually got
its own method called update which will
do its own thing
okay so
so don't worry about the actual
functionality of the methods and what
they're actually doing and the results
don't worry about that just more or less
just look at what we're actually doing
here with the class and the inheritance
okay that's the whole point in it
so we will instantiate
mapping subclass and we'll um we'll
call that or we'll
assign it to a variable called m okay
so we can then say m
items list
okay
it's the instance variable and it's an
empty
list
we will then call update
so in this case we call an update and
it's a list one two three and another
one these are values okay so now we can
quite simply
add that
and it will create um
one these two are three values okay so
what it's doing it's it's creating what
we're doing here so okay let's talk
about the method and what we're doing
because it's actually quite confusing
okay so we've got two lists it's got one
two three and these are values so what
this update method is doing it's four
item in zip and what we're doing that
that is a built-in method called zip and
it basically zips two lists together two
key value pairs
and then what we're doing is we are
using um self. items list to append item
to
the list that we just created in the
instance variable so that's why we've
got a tuple one these two are three
values that's why we've got that result
so but if we were just calling the
update
method we wouldn't get that because all
it's doing is it's iterating through
what we're passing through in this case
is it's a um
a list in a list and it's just self
items dot append and it's just appending
the item so we'd get a very different
result if we weren't
um
superseding the update method okay i
don't know if i've just butchered that
inheritance explanation but um
it's it's beginner's class so hopefully
that's given you enough to actually work
i mean i've just used the zip method
there and and um i probably could have
gone with a much more simple explanation
but
um if we were just using the base class
update method it would do one thing but
because we are actually
overwriting that update method we're
doing something very very different okay
so that is the end of this video they
are all of my code snippets that we've
walked through it's taken me nearly 20
minutes to do it
um i hope i've done it justice again
i'll just re-kind of reinforce what i
was saying this is a very much a
beginner's course or or a a polishing up
course if you like but read python's own
documentation because it will give you a
good rundown of everything in regards to
everything we've gone through in this
course actually because this is the last
video about coding the next video we'll
actually be taking what we've learned
throughout the course and just
using it to write a short program so
thank you very much for watching this
video i've enjoyed putting it together i
hope you've enjoyed it and i'll see you
in the next video thank you bye-bye
[Music]
so virtual environments today they're an
important part of any project
so we're open here on python's own
documentation on docs.python.org three
slash tutorial
v env which is shorthand for virtual
environment
okay so have a read of this in your own
time so
virtual environments why are they so
important well
when you're programming when you're a
freelancer or a software engineer or
developer whatever the case may be when
you are throughout your career working
on different projects you'll soon
realize that these projects can only
function if they've got a whole list of
different dependencies installed okay
they might be third-party packages in uh
let's say a web framework called django
you'd first have to install django and
then they say install pillow or requests
or django rest framework you would have
heard of these some of these anyway
however all of these third-party
packages will have different versions
the reason they have different versions
is because they they are configured in a
certain way to work
alongside other packages such as python
we've got python 3.10 installed or
3.10.2 installed on this project older
projects might be using python 2.7 for
instance in which case the third party
packages that you're installing have to
be
able to work with those different
dependencies and this is where virtual
environments come into it because if you
were to install all of the dependencies
globally you will have a whole bunch of
conflicts so project one will need um
python 2.7 and django
1.8 for instance and if you had all of
those installed
globally on your machine where you'd be
in a spot of bother when trying to run
project b that requires python 3.10
for instance so this is where virtual
environments come in you are able to
create this little environment on your
machine
install project dependencies within just
that environment
and fire that up and work with that
environment on your project that way you
can have one container for project one
using dependency a b and c you'll have
another project project b using
dependency uh xyz okay they are really
really helpful
now you can follow the uh walkthrough
tutorial on the page that i'm on here
using python or in my case it'll be py
dash am vnv and you can create a virtual
environment like that
by all means go ahead it'll create a
virtual environment in the um
path tree that we're in in the visual
studio code however i find
using a third-party package called
virtual env wrapper to be
a much better direction to go
so
if you visit this here which is
i'm gonna zoom in so
pypi.org project slash virtual env
wrapper sorry let's have a look again
virtually emv wrapper dash win that's
the windows version of this
what it does it allows us to install
this package globally and then we can
use commands such as make virtual
environment and then name it and it
always saves and creates and configures
a virtual environment in the same
destination normally
users slash your name slash env and then
you'll have a whole bunch of
environments very very easy to manage
whereas when you use the python
alternative this virtual environment is
saved normally in the project that
you're working in and i just find
virtually nv wrapper to be much much
easier to work with so all you do is you
copy that
command
because we've installed python globally
we have access to pypi
oh sorry pip pip
new terminal and all you need to do is
pip install
i've probably got that actually copied
on my
so copy it there
there we have it same requirements
already satisfied because i have already
got that installed globally so now what
we'll do we will go and use a command
make virtual env
and we'll call this
uh python
dash course
when i
press enter
go ahead and install or create a virtual
environment on my machine
in the folder
c drive users bobby slash env
and then there'll be a folder in there
called or directory in there called
python dash course and within there
we'll have a whole bunch of different
directory trees and um that's the
environment so that's the new um path
that we'll be using and installing
project uh installing packages into and
the reason i know it's working is
because i've got parentheses followed by
the name of the virtual env
and now that is ready for me to start
installing things so just a bit about
package manager called pip they've got
the pipi library here
and you can easily find packages by
simple google
or you can go onto the main website
and you can simply search here so one
normal a regular one that you'll see is
pillow that allows you to work with
images in python we've got record this
is one that we'll be using in this in
the next video sorry requests i want
which is a library that allows us to
make api calls so in conjunction with
other programs
you've got another one is django
rest
framework
oh whatever done there
there you go django restaurant a very
very famous third party package that you
can install that allows you to use
django just which is a web framework
just as a api backend and then you can
link the web framework with a front end
such as react for instance anyway that
is pypi that is a package manager and we
install from there using pip which is a
pip command and
let's
actually install i've already done
a virtual emv wrapper let's go pip
install
requests
you see that it's just behind my head
there but pip install requests that will
go about and i'll install requests into
that environment i might as well just
open up the environment whilst we're
here
c drive
users
bobby
envs well we've got python course python
course lovely okay so this is the
environment that we've got fired up if
you're going to lib site packages
a lot of these packages can you see that
very well
that's probably a little bit easier
right
um a lot of these packages come straight
out of the box right so
um
if i had shown you this before
installing requests it might looked a
little bit different but we've just
installed requests can you see that go
into requests and this is the requests
package there's a load of py files all
working together and all we need to do
is now import requests as a module into
our project and we have full access to
all of these files all of the classes
functions and everything else is going
on that's functioning funky in that
package we have access to if we install
it into our project it has come up with
a command here saying
you can upgrade pip so all you need to
do is just copy that part there
can you see that let me make that
there we go copy that whole part there
will go ahead and it will
update pip
and that's all you need to do so
that is virtual environments i hope i
did it justice hope you now understand
why we actually use them it's just the
way of containing all the dependencies
of your project in a nice little bubble
on your machine a nice little directory
tree so that you can access them
willy-nilly and look i can
deactivate
deactivate that so now i know the
virtual environment is no longer working
and i can say work on
demo
there is no virtual environment called
demo i think there is called demo one
there you go so i've got another virtual
environment in there called demo one so
i can turn one off and turn one on turn
one off turn on and that's a good way of
just working different projects so i
won't dribble on any longer than i need
to that's the end of this video thanks
for watching i hope you've enjoyed it i
hope you found it useful and i'll see
you in the next video where we're
designing and writing our very very
first program in this course thanks for
watching bye-bye
[Music]
okay so we're writing our first project
today with everything we've learned
throughout this course it's opened up my
vs code is opened up on project.py you
won't find that in the github repository
because i want to be coding this myself
so you can follow along with how i think
and also see how poor i am at typing
okay so you'll be following along with
this one hopefully it won't be too
clunky but um the previous
um videos
have been all prepared beforehand this
one hasn't so
hopefully you will uh see what i'm
trying to do here so the project will
consist of us writing an api which is an
application programming interface so our
program will be talking to somebody
else's program in this case it's the
chuck norris api so we'll make a request
and it will respond a joke
can't be too bad right so we will be
using the requests library which is um
something we installed in the last video
into our virtual env that is a library
specifically for this so we use requests
to make get post put and delete requests
to apis and get a response so that's
what we're going to do
so if i open a terminal
if i go
work on
python
course
that will fire up the virtual
environment because i've got a
parenthesis there
and if i now put pip freeze
that will list everything that's
installed in that virtual environment
you can see here we've got requests
because we installed that in the last
video so happy days let's close that
down on minimize that we don't need it
so if you watch the models video a
modules video should i say you will know
that we can now import requests
because it's in our virtual environment
so it's in our extended directory
directory tree we will also import now
we'll leave it as requests
so
i'm going to be using classes um because
i want to show you a base class in the
real world and a derived class so we use
a base class to
make the request to make the call and
i'll use the derived class to actually
build the request itself and then maybe
call the functional sorted method in in
the base class so that's what we'll try
and do we'll be using an if statement
maybe or a match statement we'll be
writing or erasing uh type errors or
exceptions
and uh using f string so we'll be
basically using a lot of stuff we've
learned not everything but so you'll be
able to see that i'm using certain
things that i know from my python skills
and actually um writing a program with
it so without further ado
let's jump straight into it so that's
right class
and we'll call this api call
nice and simple and we use a text
literal
to say
base class to make a basic
api call with
requests
happy days
uh and then what we will do is so
the method we'll use this will kind of
be a global method that will be a
we can use this across numerous apis
that's why we're putting in a base base
class so this one just needs to be a
method that allows us to call
and we'll pass through itself so we'll
pass for the instance of itself and what
we need to have posted through
would be the method
so get post put delete so method
and also the endpoint the api so api
let's go url okay
so
first thing we want to do is
do a if statement we'll do an if
statement so if
method
method equals equals
no method lower so we don't know if
there's going to be uppercase or not
equals equals get
then we'll do something
so
get we will make the request itself so r
dot requests
dot get
we'll pass through api url okay nice and
easy
now we could use an else statement
i'll use i'll raise exceptions later on
this won't be it's something that you
can you would have to change this if
you're going to use this in your own
program because we need to capture the
post to put the delete methods also
so we're not going to use an else or an
if else or anything like that because to
save time
but we will now do a match
on uh the response so with requests you
get a um status that you can tap into a
status code that you can use to check
whether or not the api call was a
success a success is 200 or 201
depends on the api
um but we want to check to make sure
that the status code of the api response
is
200 and if it is then we'll return and
if not we'll raise a type error okay so
match
uh r dot status code
there we go and we'll have a case
statement for this
and that will be 200
we'll have a little bar
201
this is basically saying or
and in which case we want to
return
and we just let's just return a string
no it will be r dot
jason
and i think it comes back as text
obviously this will you can change this
um
as value
so this particular api is it returns a
response jason you you can then get the
uh text specific text for this called
value now obviously that's not going to
be the same on every api but let's
assume it is for this in this example
then we'll have another case statement
which catches everything else
and we'll say raise
type error
we'll just say api error shall we
so if it isn't com if it does come back
as
200 it would just raise
api error
not the best description but you can
imagine using you can use different um
exceptions and different strings and and
what have you and it can just basically
work through the different exceptions so
this is the cool method that we'll be
using in our
uh derived class so we're gonna put
class
and we'll call this
chuck
norris and we will be putting api call
in there because this is the base class
for the derived class we'll have another
text literal and we'll say
this is the um chuck norris api
doesn't really matter for this example
but you can add a description
okay so we want a cloud because this is
specific for chuck norris we can have a
class variable called
url
and what i'll do i'll put https
and this is
api dot oh
api dot
chuck noise
dot io
that's not gonna work
all right stop io
slash jokes
slash random
question mark
cat ergory
equals
okay and then what we'll do we'll
construct uh api url by using a
placeholder okay and i'll show you what
that means in a second
categories equals and we'll have we'll
just have
animal
and also they have one called dev as
well they have more but we'll keep it as
their animal
and
then we will
i'm not gonna add that now we will have
uh thunder in it so
in it we'll pass through self as we
normally do and we'll also pass through
category because this will allow us to
instantiate the class with animal or dev
okay so we'll have self
dot category
equals cat gory
there we go and then
now you could have if
not
self dot category in categories
do you know what we'll write it cat
self dot category sorry
so this is if instance variable is not
in class variable categories then we can
then raise
type error
cat not
options
animal
dev okay
so that's just the type error that will
be shown
now we'll have def and we'll have this
one called get we'll pass through self
so this is the get request for the
derived class you can also have a post
request put request well it depends on
what you want to do and how you want to
construct it but essentially the first
thing we want to do here is we want to
construct the api url so we want to use
an f string
with placeholders
the first place holder will be
self.url
because that is the class variable we've
got here okay
the second one we want to pass through
the category that we're passing through
so it's self dot
category okay and then what we can do is
return
self dot call this is the base class
function this one here you can see we
need a password method an api url
so we'll go
these are um
positional arguments we don't need to um
use keywords so we can put get or you
can even put get like that because we're
actually using the lower method
and
then we'll have api
url we don't need to use self because
this this is just a variable that we're
using within the function there or in a
method
and
is that coming through value
return.json
yeah that should that just just return
the string so that'll be just string
that looks like it could work okay so
i'm gonna make i'm gonna go ahead and
test that
hopefully that'll work so let's go
terminal and what we'll do we'll go work
on
python
course
that will fire up the virtual
environment i know that because i've got
parentheses followed by the name of the
virtual environment now we'll fire up
our
uh python interpreter so we can use the
modules import so import
projects
or project which is this file here okay
so we're importing project into the
python interpreter and now what we can
do is
we can go
api
call
dot
doc
api call not found oh sorry project
dot api call
dot
dot
there we go so that we're using the
dunder dock method there to just print
out the text literal uh actually what
we'll do is import no from
from
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter okay
so we now have access to these classes
in our python interpreter so now what
we'll do we will instantiate of
chuck norris to a variable c so e
if we go
project
chuck
norris
and remember we need to pass through a
category so if i just put a it'll come
through and say look category options
animal dev because we've got the type
error but if we were to put through
animal
we've now got c
so i can say c
dot
the get do i call it get
yeah there we go get and we'll pass
through
actually we don't need to pass through
anything
will this work
happy days it works so
we're just called the get method the get
method has constructed a url and then
it's called the self call method from
the base class password get the new url
and then it's gone around and followed
this match statement so it's matched we
used an if statement for the actual get
request we could have used a match
statement and then we used a match
statement with a case statement to look
at the status code if the status code
matches all of this then we get the
value keyword from the json response
and then we just return it into the
python interpreter so what is that joe
what have we got
they say curiosity killed the cat
this is false chuck norris killed the
cat every single one of them okay and
then you can do it again
oh is it always coming back for the same
i know so it's the same on the first
time then it made another call so chuck
norris once rode a nine foot grizzly
bear through an automatic car wash
instead of taking a shower okay should
we make one more
oh it's the same one it keeps coming up
with the same one
there we go so that works that is the
project you can see
if we go back to the code here you could
easily
just create a new class
and we could call this
nasa
yeah we can make an api call to the nasa
api we would just need to change the url
we change the categories if that was
indeed the case if there wasn't
categories if there was a few different
sorts of categories um i know in a nasa
api they've got different cameras
um and
what have you so you might would just
configure the class slightly different
but what won't change or possibly won't
change is the call method in here and if
it was to change slightly you could
overwrite it or extend it in the um
derived class okay
so
i'm really happy with that that actually
did work really really well
so
that is the end of this course we've
written our first project um it's an api
uh call to the chuck norris api it
worked really well we're using classes
base classes derived classes match
statements if statements we're using
strings we're using um
all sorts of stuff we're using lists
here um you could even go one step
further and you can you can maybe do a
random pick of all of the different
categories so you always got a
randomized response rather than animal
so when you're instantiating it
you won't get similar jokes but
hopefully you can see now from this
project that
you know the world is your oyster just
play
you've spent the last few hours going
through this course i've showed you the
absolute basics what i think are the
fundamentals of understanding python
okay take what you've learned write some
programs that is the best possible way
that you can learn how to code in python
also always reference back to this cheat
sheet i'll say it again you can clone
this down for my github repository this
is your cheat sheet please please please
use it
in two years time
or the two months time you might look
back and go oh what did i what was that
about dictionaries what was that about
tuples why can't i do x y and z what are
the methods
whatever the case may be you've got a
cheat sheet so clone it down it's for
you i made it for you so
like i say this is the last video this
is the end of the course i have
thoroughly enjoyed putting it together i
hope
i truly hope that you've enjoyed
watching it please please please
get in touch if you have any questions
whatsoever thank you very much for
watching and i will see you in the next
course thank you bye